while some higher level researchers
specialized guards and containment
experts at the SCP Foundation have fixed
anomalous projects tailored to their
very particular set of skills for many
lower level operatives including Junior
researchers guards janitorial staff and
even the dreaded d-classes every day is
showing up spinning the wheel of
Misfortune and finding out how you might
die today will you be hacked to Pieces
by a murder monster pulled into a portal
turned into a doll eaten alive made into
a living Nest by bugs stretched out and
broken drowned exsanguinated set on fire
beaten to death by a volley of anomalous
tomatoes because you decided to drop a
cringe-worthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course Chief among these is the
legendary
scp-999 also known by its adorable occur
the Tickle Monster we don't need to get
into too much detail in describing this
gelatinous ray of sunshine his anomalous
delightfulness has made him somewhat of
a celebrity compared to the murderer's
row of terrifying entities and monsters
around him the researcher assigned to
him today was troubled having seen one
of his favorite co-workers devoured by
scp-682 the day before getting assigned
to feeding and checking on scp-999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M M's in hand
the creature cooed perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured M
M's into its eager mouth radiating Good
Vibes the whole time what an asset what
a gift and to think this adorable little
goober was prophesized to someday save
the world that much seemed almost funny
but he was certainly more than capable
of saving the life of someone who hadn't
felt the warmth of internal sunshine in
quite some time and for that much the
researcher was profoundly grateful he
left 999's chamber that day with a
renewed sense of hope for the future
that maybe just maybe they might be able
to pull through to make a difference to
push this crazy ball of rock we call our
home in the right direction maybe
someday the Sun would rise on a perfect
world who would have thought that a
strange Sunrise could change everything
emergency Sirens went off across the
globe but in every case they were
drowned out by a terrible endless chorus
of Screams but below all that you'll
hear another gut-wrenching sound a low
but pervasive sizzling like an egg on a
hot pan as billions of human beings
started to change their states of matter
the SCP Foundation had fought off and
contained so many seemingly possible
threats from interdimensional Horrors
like the hanged sealed and Scarlet Kings
to nightmarish Mass Killers like
scp-106 the old man
scp-096 the Shy Guy and scp-682 the hard
to destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good would
any of it do when the very center of our
solar system decided in an instant that
rather being the linchpin of our
delicate cradle of life it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was
answered upon the emergence of
scp-001 a terrible day also known as
when day breaks in the snap of one's
fingers half the world was plunged into
Terror and death rays of Stark red light
swept through the streets people lucky
enough to be in the shade or inside
buildings with a view to the outside saw
the people in the streets seize up and
begin to shriek in terrible pain their
skin sagged and their bones liquefied
their bodies dropped down to the ground
and coalesced into gurgling wretching
Puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this Abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas an
afterimage burned into the plasma of an
old TV screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden Insanity taking over the
world caused the SCP Foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
Shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary Foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that Humanity could live on in
the dark thankfully the very concept of
the day gave them one advantage while
one side of the Earth was effectively
doomed the second the process us began
the other side had a 12-hour Head Start
before the sun turned its terrible eye
to them sirens went off in the middle of
the night waking people up groggy
rubbing the sleep on their eyes every
television and radio and
internet-enabled device in their home
was playing the same message direct from
the SCP Foundation which now had
effectively commandeered the entire U.S
government along with the rest of the
world it gave them directions to the
nearest Foundation containment site and
told them that if they didn't
immediately comply and find their way to
safety they would experience a terrible
death by sunrise and if you're at all
familiar with human beings you've
probably already predicted that they
didn't just calmly wrap themselves up
make their way to their cars and form an
orderly line to the various Foundation
containment sites located around them it
was in fact total pandemonium as the
solar clock ticked down slowly marking
off the seconds that anyone outside had
left to live the only human beings with
a meaningful head start began to go
insane in a number of varied and
interesting ways some who took the
situation seriously and acknowledged
that the sun was indeed going to wipe
out most of humanity simply cracked
under the pressure there were those who
went into totally catatonic States
rocking back and forth in the corner and
refusing to respond to any stimuli some
became erratic and violent with
unpredictable behavior that harmed
themselves and others after all what was
the point in acting normally anymore
when the complete crumbling of human
civilization was imminent and their only
hope was some shadowy organization
they'd never heard of some not heeding
the warning seriously enough and
prompted by greed and opportunism tried
to take advantage of the situation
financially some smashed Windows of
local stores and looted or broke into
the homes of neighbors who had already
fled in hopes of proloing their property
others were a little more creative
setting up short term Everything Must Go
nighttime fire sales for their brands of
essential oils neurotropics and
nutraceuticals claiming all of them had
the power to ward off or cure the new
effects of the sun others completely
denied the possibility that any of this
was real and claimed that the messages
from this so-called SCP Foundation were
actually just a front to take away their
freedoms and trap them in underground
government camps they staunchly refused
to follow any of the safety guidelines
that the SCP Foundation put out claiming
if you try to take away my first
amendment rats you're gonna take away my
second amendment rats while riding
around in their pickup trucks and SUVs
blasting Kid Rocks don't tell me how to
live at ear splitting volumes naturally
they had all melted into screeching
puddles of liquid flash by Sunrise some
were not victims of their own bizarre
choices but were doomed by the sudden
terrible fear and panic of the
circumstances themselves the highways
were gridlocked cars stuck as far as the
eye could see so many had rushed to
escape during the initial wave that
means of Transport soon became choke
points liked clogged arteries in a dying
man people do irrational things when
they're scared riots broke out in the
streets fighting killing burning
everyone hoping for some means of meager
control over a situation that had long
been out of any of their hands some were
too far away with not enough time to
close the distance what could they
really do but just sit around and wait
to die the hours marched on as the earth
made its slow turn towards the sun
leaving one decimated half in darkness
and the other a Sitting Duck for its
terrible effects hundreds of thousands
had made their way to the containment
sites and safely gotten inside but still
so many millions were left outside it
was a slaughterhouse one great big
Global meat grinder and every moment
that passed the handle turned and any
humans left outside got just that little
bit closer to the grinding gnashing
gears below site 19 being the largest
containment site on the foundation books
also became Humanity's only Bastion it
was the great hope of escape from the
horrors going on outside the foundation
had figured out so many ways of
counteracting deadly anomalous forces
before given enough time and enough
Personnel surely they could figure out a
solution to even this this was however
when the most startling realization yet
swept over all the survivors those who
were melted by the sudden hostile Sun
weren't dead they were very much alive
in fact but they'd been changed in both
body and mind what had once been humans
now became terrible beasts half-melted
gelatinous nightmares that coagulated
into even bigger beasts they got into
their head that they were grateful for
the transformation that they had been
liberated from their old forms in the
old world they were something so much
more now and they wanted everyone else
to join them in their Liberation
survivors outside the foundation
containment sites were systematically
hunted by these great masses of altered
flesh even though smart enough to cover
every inch of their bodies with clothes
to protect from the Sun to only move at
night to carry weapons were dragged out
by meaty tendrils from their refuge in
the basements and the lightless hearts
of buildings dragged into the Searing
gaze of the sun to melt to change to
coalesce into something greater it was
the inevitable fate of all of humanity
when most of the stragglers were dragged
out and changed the flush masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
holed up at site 19 there was one
consolation out there to help
scp-999 the foundation was at War with
the sun and its terrible disciples and
contrary to many people's beliefs it
takes more than men equipment and
bullets to win a war 999 provided the
essential element that brought it all
together morale hope the will to go on
even when it seemed like all could be
lost after a long day of battling the
fleshy Abominations At The Gates
Foundation guards mobile task force
members and even civilian volunteers
were drained and traumatized by the
horrors that they'd seen once a day was
over 999 would move among the ranks
cuddling up to them warding off the
despair that was easy to set in during
the downswing of a terrible apocalypse
like this without his presence there
would be no hope of fighting that good
fight so many of them would have given
up walked into the Sun and joined the
Monstrous Force they were fighting after
all they seemed happy enough and it
would certainly be easier 999 had become
once again an indispensable asset to the
SCP Foundation the solar betrayal may
not have been the Scarlet King's doing
while as far as our current Intel
suggests anyway but he was playing a
crucial part in saving the world exactly
as predicted 999 didn't fully understand
what was going on outside sometimes why
there seemed to be fewer people as the
weeks went on and why the people there
seemed so sad all the time whenever he
wasn't helping them but he was more than
happy to help whatever the case many of
the humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically pose no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class cots which had been repurposed
into more sleep keeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slithering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crime it was a woman
with an unfamiliar face probably one of
the rare new refugees bawling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question official orders stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
scp-999 isn't by any definition a human
when night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 999 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the Foundation might try to stop
it when it came to saving this little
boy 999 refused to let anyone stop it
999 slithered out and threw the broken
streets there were no bodies of course
it seemed even the dead could be revived
and assimilated through the power of the
sun talk about a mixed Miracle but the
broken down World outside site 19
undeniably reflected the pandemonium
that took place here 999 would need to
do his best to find the little boy
trapped out here before the sun rose he
lost a few hours even finding his way to
the nearest town where it was safe to
assume that the little boy was trapped
he saw those things on the way there
those moving wailing mountains of melted
human flesh each talking and shattering
to themselves in a hundred different
dead voices 999 had been cross-tested
with scp-682 and still those monsters
frightened him he decided it would be
best to stay away from them and make
sure that they never saw him out of here
eventually 999 reached the town
similarly dilapidated and broken down in
the months since the world as we had all
known it disappeared an array of
terrible Sunshine more great gibbering
Blobs of Flesh patrolled the streets
looking for converts to integrate into
their biomass 999 could only hope it
wasn't already too late for the little
boy 999 discreetly slithered from
building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the sadness and the
fear radiating off of him as it was the
creature's natural instinct to help the
needy and to use those signals like a
home dream to find the scared little boy
he did an inside a broom closet and was
quietly weeping into his hands he hadn't
eaten in days and was only surviving by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
bucket sitting next to him 999
immediately embraced the boy covering
him in its healing energy until the
tears of the boy's face eventually Drive
999 cooed and chirped pleasantly until
the little boy was laughing again but
this momentary Joy was soon interrupted
a great heaving weight dragged itself
down the hall outside both 999 and the
boy could sense its monstrous presence
as it got closer they could hear all
those chattering voices those poisonous
Whispers when it passed the door they
heard it speaking its voice practically
vibrating with the hum of malicious
lunacy
feel it on your face feel yourself
change
us become one with our army of One it
must be soulful
Little Flower walk into the Sun and be
us 999 and the boy remain silent in the
broom closet for hours as the great
shape patrolled the bank outside
searching for converts for victims at
times it seemed too frightening to even
breathe fearing that would be enough to
make the monster detect them it felt
like an eternity until the monster
eventually did slope off and leave them
in the comforting quiet and darkness of
the closet now they might be free 999
could escort the boy safely back to the
containment site and into the arms of
his terrified mother but when they
opened the door they saw a terrible
sight light in the distance pouring
through the windows in the glass double
doors it wouldn't be safe to go out that
way upon seeing this and putting
together what it meant the boy began to
cry he couldn't take another night in
the closet it was all going to wither
from here until 999 had a wonderful idea
hours later when the foundation's guards
manned the turrets at the entrance of
site 19 waiting for the inevitable
onslaught of the melted flesh creatures
they tensed up seeing a blobbing
gelatinous form slithering towards them
in the distance the guards who'd learned
the hard way from too many lost men that
it was better to be safe than sorry Drew
a bead on the distant shape and prepared
to fire when suddenly their Superior
raced a hand and said wait hold fire is
that 999 on and it was they all stared
in astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
an amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
Hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way for a lot of people
scp-999 really was saving the world or
what was left of it anyway almost all
cross-testing to kill or pacify scp-682
had failed miserably if you haven't seen
it go watch our video on the legendary
hard to kill reptile to see just how
powerful and terrifying this creature is
it faced the gate Guardian an SCP with a
flaming sword hotter than the sun
capable of tearing your atoms to shreds
and came out fine in its Face-Off with a
horrifying scp-096 also known as the shy
guy it broke the Shy Guy's mind and
reduced it to gibbering despair even
scps with supposedly unlimited Powers
simply refuse to engage the beast in
combat
so when it was proposed that they test
682 with scp-999 a creature known among
Foundation staff as the Tickle Monster
the idea was considered laughable 682
had been burned suffocated cut up
incinerated and growled in the faces of
the Gods how could this so-called Tickle
Monster ever hope to survive an
encounter let alone win a fight some
even believe that this was the last we'd
see of scp-999
but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover
scp-999 is an amazing and unique SCP in
and of itself
but its secret Origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the SCP Universe are what
make this humble slimy creature Beyond
extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
Yes you heard that right the
heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail placed 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past caused minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long-lasting damage of
any kind to a living thing even its diet
consists only of candy and sweets with a
particular preference for M M's and Neko
Wafers it consumes these treats through
the cell membrane of its slimy body much
like an amoeba this extremely stretchy
membrane means the creature is highly
malleable including the ability to
stretch and flatten itself out to a mere
two centimeters thick at rest the
creature takes a dome-like shape around
2 meters wide and 1 meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are prehenso pseudopods those are
the arm-like projections normally seen
on single-celled organisms of which it
has at least three the more you hear
about this utterly harmless creature the
more that matching it up with the pure
embodiment of absolute hatred known as
scp-682 feels downright cruel in
absolute contrast to the misanthropic
attitudes of the reptile 999 loves
humans it has a playful dog-like
attitude much like an over-excited puppy
when approached 999 will react with
extreme joy and slithered towards the
nearest person in order to interact it
will leap onto them using two of its
three prehensile pseudopods to hug the
person while the third nuzzles the
person's face emitting high-pitched
cooing and gurgling noises throughout
the creature is apparently Pleasant in
every conceivable fashion as even its
odor has been reported to smell just
like the favorite scent of whoever is
smelling it examples have included
chocolate fresh laundry bacon roses and
Play-Doh it's almost impossible to
oversell just how beloved and benevolent
this strange creature is it's one of the
rare Sapient scps to earn the safe class
and it's allowed to roam freely around
its facility at all times apart from a
one-hour bedtime period between 8 and 9
pm in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally fetted a can of caffeinated
Cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
Whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered Monster the employees
observing the tests watched in suspense
says 999 began to enthusiastically
Slither towards 682. it's no surprise
that after being tortured and almost
killed hundreds of times during testing
682 had grown jaded to the Cross test it
was regularly subjected to when it saw
this strange orange blob squelching
across the ground towards it its side
and groaned expecting the worst
what is that the creature asked of its
gelatinous guest
scp-9999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682's
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682's acid eaten face began to slowly
change it was beginning to smile
observers recorded a noise what they
thought could have been a chuckle as the
creature growled and said
what is this
I feel
good
while The Observers looked on stunned at
what was happening 999 began to Slither
and crawl up from between 682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck there it began to nuzzle like it
had never nuzzled before the results
spoke for themselves 682 was grinning
and chuckling repeating a phrase that
the foundation never would have imagined
coming from 682
feels so happy happy
happy
just when you thought scp-999 couldn't
possibly be more adorable you learn
about its greatest power bringing Joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing will experience a kind of mild
Euphoria as one's contact with the
creature is prolonged this overwhelming
sense of Joy increases and continues
long after you've separated from it
prolonged contact has completely cured
depression anxiety and PTSD along with a
number of other conditions including
rage and anti-social personality
disorders serial killers practically
become Saints after coming into
prolonged contact with 999 and in that
moment 682 was no exception and there
truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to scp-999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more scp-999
also appears to have an innate sense for
those who need its help most with a
particular affection for the hurt and
the unhappy the creature appears to be a
true altruist on a fundamental level
even risking its own safety to help
humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one SCP who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the Beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that The
Observers in attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter it rolled onto its back
slamming its huge tail against the door
it had just Fallen victim to one of
999's favorite pastimes tickle fights
hence how it earned its Tickle Monster
nickname among staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face after 15 minutes
of inactivity two d-class Personnel were
commanded to enter and retrieve scp-999
from the containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its Lumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all Personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent Rampage
however in spite of this 999 showed no
fear and helped save some of the
bystanders as security officers subdued
and recaptured 682 and even after all of
this 999 showed no hard feelings towards
682 and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so Limitless that it's practically
immune to fear which is all well and
good because the true enemy that 999 is
destined to face is infinitely more
powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be what is this monster and
why should 999 have to face it someday
the answers to these questions all lie
in the true origins of scp-999 available
only to those with level 5 clearance and
Beyond it's a perfect example of how
something good can come from the darkest
places there would be no scp-9999
without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual perform formed by a cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King
these girls over the years that followed
gave birth to some of the most horrific
monsters imaginable
one of which According to some was
scp-682
these beings were manifested by the
Scarlet King a powerful interdimensional
nightmare God believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within R and many other
dimensions Foundation higher-ups have
declared the Scarlet King to be the
greatest existing threat to the
Multiverse at large an scp-231 was his
latest direct interaction with our
universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to scp-999 a being of pure
goodness that's right the nicest kindest
cuddliest SCP of all is the direct
descendant of a being that's essentially
the dark God of all evil feel free to
take a moment to absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments scp-999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a Scarlet king-aligned culture
known as the DeVos
scp-9999 is still very much in its
infancy yet it already has the power to
pacify its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed According to some
prophecies and Foundation theories that
the power of scp-9999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable Scarlet King
himself not through violence or hate but
through the pure force of happiness and
love burning out the darkness and
purifying the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors to
those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful and valuable scps in
existence and may be the greatest asset
in the foundation's Arsenal for the war
against dangerous anomalous activity
after all what could strike more fear
into their hearts than the knowledge
that it might be love rather than
Firepower that finally dethrones the
Scarlet King
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we know from a fate
so much worse than death with nothing
but affection for everyone and
everything it's worth offering thanks to
the little orange blob or at least an
extra pack of M M's before bedtime the
Scarlet King is a really bad guy he's a
giant interdimensional nightmare God
intent on breaching our reality and
Wrecking terrible havoc on everything we
know and love he's been responsible for
Untold suffering and Chaos across
countless worlds timelines and layers of
reality to many he's even somewhat of a
final boss to the SCP Foundation and
just when you think he couldn't get any
worse it turns out that he's also a
deadbeat dad not only did the Scarlet
King once have a cult literally named
the children of the Scarlet King before
it was destroyed by Dr Montauk in the
SCP Foundation he also had at least
seven actual children each one is
speculated to be a powerful anomaly but
it's tough to to find concrete answers
as to who or what exactly most of them
are so today we're putting on our
researcher hats and digging deep into
the foundation's lore to present our
theories on the potential progeny of the
SCP foundation's greatest enemy and if
nothing else we may finally be able to
get this dark lord of all evil to start
paying all the child support he probably
owes by now first if you're not well
versed in Scarlet King lore you may be
wondering how exactly does an evil chaos
God have kids is there a Scarlet Queen
out there who prefers to stay out of the
Limelight the answer isn't quite that
simple and it has everything to do with
scp-231 and Big Red's most devoted cult
the non-biological Children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as
scp-231 anyone who accesses those files
and trust us they aren't a pretty sight
we'll find that the containment
procedures mostly involve performing the
infamous Montauk procedure on the
surviving girls to keep them from giving
birth six of the Seven Brides have given
birth to nightmares Beyond Comprehension
and are now dead with only one still
remaining successfully contained but
here at the SCP Foundation you need to
learn to comprehend the incomprehensible
according to a classified document
scp-231 May technically be a neutralized
anomaly without us even knowing and
incidentally this gives us our most
certain answer on the children of the
Scarlet King on this one the Apple fell
very very far from the tree according to
the secret document
scp-999 that's right the adorable Tickle
Monster is the seventh child of the
Scarlet King he must be so disappointed
that everyone's favorite little blob
didn't want to join the family business
of absolute evil for anyone who doesn't
know
scp-999 is a slimy yellow entity that
only seems capable of absolute
compassion it brings joy to everyone in
its presence and with prolonged exposure
it can even cure disorders like PTSD
anxiety and depression he's so good at
this that he even cured
scp-231-7 his de facto mother of her
trauma and allowed her to return happily
to her family after some amnestic
treatment the Scarlet King has another
good reason to be ashamed of his
cheerful blobby's son ancient dividi
prophecy dictates that scp-999 may
someday become so powerful that his
force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet Kings evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if scp-999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend
scp-682 the malicious lizard heavily
implied to be a child of the Scarlet
King if you know literally anything
about 682 your reaction to finding out
that he's the spawn of Cruelty
personified is probably yeah that makes
sense just as scp-999 is the Scarlet
King's innocent optimistic young child
682 is kind of like his edgy teenager
still in the middle of a misanthropic
phase he shows no sign of leaving
anytime soon the fact that 682 appears
to find anything about the world around
him utterly disgusting seems to be a
trade he inherited from his dear old dad
and the fact he seems pretty much
impossible to kill also lends Credence
to the popular Theory he's got nightmare
God blood running through his veins 682
has also started displaying a particular
hatred for 999 ever since an incident
where 999 tickled him into submission so
family dinners are probably extra
awkward for these two 999 and 682 are
the most certain children but that still
leaves us with five more children to
identify it's worth remembering that the
waters are murkier from here on in but
we've searched far and wide through the
foundation archives to find possible
answers if your interpretation differs
remember that it's just a theory an SCP
explained Theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here the tail dust and
blood hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
scp-239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like scp-682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr clef has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening wonderkin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory
scp-029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
to suggest that she's got an extremely
Sinister father she also fits the
profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trance-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Khali the Hindu God of
destruction whom has many similarities
to the Scarlet King she certainly fits
the bill of someone capable of raising
armies in the Dark Lord's name one
strike against our Scarlet King
connection theory is that the file
States the daughter of Darkness was
first discovered in India which wouldn't
match up with the other information we
know to be fact however while this is a
long shot given the sensitive nature of
everything involving the Scarlet King
it's extremely possible that false
information was supplied to bury the
connection considering the cover-ups and
lies involving anomalies like scp-1000
this certainly isn't an unprecedented
move on the part of the foundation next
the third child this child is associated
with all things desolation implying
destruction fire ashes pestilence and
death across the battlefield when it
comes to spreading destruction and Death
on a mass scale one particular SCP comes
to mind
scp-058 the Heart of Darkness this
creature has Scarlet King written all
over it it's evil it's mysterious it's
pretty much impossible to kill and it
causes Mass casualties every time it
escapes its containment chamber it
causes fires whips people to death with
its razor-sharp tendrils and spraying's
highly corrosive acid from its
scorpion-like tail and it's even red
said given that we know for a fact this
entity suddenly emerged out of something
that's now been expunged from the
records in an undisclosed site it's
extremely possible that the entity 058
came from was
scp-231-3 this is a child that the
Scarlet king would definitely be proud
of given that it's impossible to reason
with and feels solely motivated by
causing destruction misery and Chaos we
can't think of an entity that better
suits the Desolation moniker than
scp-058 next skipping past scp-682 at
number four the fifth child of the
Scarlet King is associated with the
loose concept of lack the prophecy then
goes into more detail saying that this
child is powerful in the ways of magic
and is able to use their abilities to
cause great destruction here we have
another unconventional proposal what if
child number five wasn't actually a
child but children that's because we
think this description perfectly fits
scp-1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
bride now hear us out these are actually
some of the most powerful enemies the
foundation has ever attempted to contain
and we know nothing about their past
before being bound to a few objects by
the Serpent's hand these sadistic
reality warpers are so devastatingly
powerful that the only action the
foundation can take against them is
letting them have free Reign Over the
containment site they currently inhabit
all the foundation can do is hope they
never get bored of tormenting the people
inside as we all know the Scarlet King
despises science progress and order so
perhaps a perfect punishment for the
foundation in his many eyes is giving
them a taste of their own medicine the
sisters though particularly their
ringleader are perverse shadow of the
foundation's love of the scientific
method they take these methods and use
them for an act activity that the
Scarlet King finds much more enjoyable
tormenting and killing people whenever
these crafty triplets set their mind to
it their horrifically powerful magic is
able to cause massive Devastation just
like the prophecy for the fifth bride's
Offspring dictates and finally the sixth
child of the Scarlet King the concept
associated with this one is hidden
meaning it can change its face and walk
unnoticed through creation it's also
said to have the responsibility of
opening the ways between worlds and
allowing the war to end all wars to
first begin there have been a huge
number of guesses for this spot with
some even suggesting
scp-055 the anti-mean but since we're
having fun here we also want to make an
even Wilder suggestion we posit that the
sixth child of the Scarlet King is
Alison Chow also known as LS and the
black queen the most powerful member of
the Serpent's hand we get it we have a
lot of explaining to do but hear us out
Alison Chao is a member of the Serpent's
hand or technically many members
multiple versions of her exist across
parallel dimensions in the SCP
Multiverse they're mostly all as strange
Daughters of foundation researcher Dr
Charles kears this estrangement leads
them to collaborate in The Wanderers
Library the secret base of the Serpent's
hand to conduct raids on the foundation
in Revenge but what if the leader of
these alternate allicins had an ulterior
motive because in the infinite number of
possibilities offered by the Multiverse
this one was not the daughter of Charles
gears but the Scarlet King she's merely
using the pain of her counterparts to
manipulate them into accomplishing her
true father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesized to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Allison Chao appear human the use of
scp-268 a Newsboy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnotic allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
King's entrance into our Dimension and
Allison Chao has access to The Wanderers
Library an unfettered access point
between Dimensions if one of the
infinite allisons was the secret
daughter of the Scarlet King with The
Wanderers Library not be a perfect way
for him to leave his own Dimension and
enter ours she could be the final piece
he needs hidden under the nose of the
foundation and the Serpent's hand making
all the secret power plays to allow for
the Scarlet King's eventual bloody
revenge on our world unless of course
scp-999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us anytime
life at the SCP Foundation isn't exactly
made up of sunshine and rainbows it's
less of a good vibes kind of place and
more of a this is the solemn work we do
as we stand between humanity and the
vast unfeeling a noble realm of mystery
and darkness sure sometimes there's a
magic vending machine or a teddy bear
doctor but most of the time the
foundation's findings are a lot more
bite than they are bar thankfully
there's the C portion of that Infamous
acronym contain they keep their bizarre
astounding findings locked up tight
where they can't catch an unsuspecting
innocent off guard and
oh hey there little buddy it's okay you
didn't mean to scare me relax everyone
it's just scp-999 one of the only
contained Curiosities allowed to roam
freely around the halls of the
foundation just look at this guy as a
sentient mass of translucent orange
slime ever been so cute you want some
chocolate buddy okay here you go it's
incredible really that the place that
houses a neck snapping sculpture and a
haunted chess playing machine could also
be the home of such a delightful little
blob you know now that I think of it
it's amazing that being in the vicinity
of unspeakable Horrors day after day has
never put a damper on 999's positive
attitude he's got the persistent
cheerful disposition of a Labrador puppy
but how well would scp-9999's inherent
wholesomeness hold up against one of the
most wicked anomalies contained by the
SCP Foundation what would happen if the
lightest of the light a slimy piece of
pure goodness came up against a deep
dark evil not the omnicidal Rage of
scp-682 we all all know how that went
but something quieter well let's find
out
scp-999 was having the best day of its
life to be fair every single day was the
best day of the tickle Monster's life
surpassed only by the day that followed
and the one after that and how could it
not be a good life at the SCP Foundation
when there were so many friends to play
with treats to eat and so much to
explore
scp-999 was enjoying a hearty bowl of M
Ms picking out and eating the orange
ones its favorites first when a familiar
figure walked into its pen Dr Jack
Bright who frequently came by to see the
Tickle Monster when he was having a
disappointing day usually because the
higher-ups had reprimanded him for
breaking the rules yet again
scp-999 cooed delightfully at the site
of its visitor slithering over to Dr
Brighton enveloping him in an
enthusiastic hug Dr bright immediately
began to laugh as the creature's
euphoric influence took effect hey glad
there are no hard feelings about the
time I ate a piece of you
uh he giggled that's 999 patted his face
affectionately with one of its
pseudopods ah thanks that really takes
the sting out of getting the no
chainsaws Hammer brought down on me
again he patted the slime with his own
hand in return and satisfied that it had
sufficiently cheered him 999 ooze back
over to its breakfast to finish
consuming the sugary goodness oh I
almost forgot Dr bright pulled something
out of his lab coat pocket it was a
small can of cola appealingly shiny in
the light want some scp-999 gurgled
curiously and approached Dr bright to
inspect the can he popped it open with
an inviting Fizz and offered some
fortunately Dr Rhodes was walking by at
that exact moment don't you dare she
snatched the can out of her colleague's
hand you remember what happened last
time 999 can't tolerate caffeine or
carbonation Dr bright pouted like a
petulant child but I wanted to see it
bounce do I need to add another rule to
the list Dr Rhodes crossed her arms or
are you going to behave yourself oh fine
whatever I'll find something else to do
Dr bright rolled his eyes and left
scp-999's pen with a final friendly wave
of the creature sensing Dr Rhodes's
stress the Tickle Monster nuzzled her
leg with an inquisitive gurgle she
smiled indulgently and gave the Slime a
hug before she followed Dr bright down
the hall keeping an eye out for any more
potentially disruptive Antics satisfied
at having cheered everyone up scp-999
went back to its bowl of candy and
devoured the remaining trees but then
there was nothing left to eat and no one
in the room to visit or play with what
was a lovable slime to do why explore of
course
scp-999 had the freedom to roam all over
the foundation site until bedtime that
is and it loved oozing down the Halls
looking for friends to greet and
strangers to meet after all a stranger
is just a friend that the Tickle Monster
hasn't tickled yet as the Slime slid
along the floor it took the time to say
hello to everyone it passed by bumping
them nudging them or in the case of
Josie the half cat very gently petting
her head with one of its pseudopods the
cat purred and 999 responded by
vibrating its gelatinous body producing
a soft purr of its own then Josie was
distracted by a dust particle drifting
through a beam of light and darted off
to chase it so the Tickle Monster
continued on its way looking for
something new and fun to do it spotted
the perfect new activity two guards were
walking into one of the sealed
containment rooms a room that the Jolly
little slime had never been inside of
before now was the perfect chance to
investigate and maybe play tickle
wrestling with the guards along the way
it had to act fast though the door was
beginning to close rearranging its body
999 squished itself into a long thin
line sliding quickly through the crack
in the door just before it shut this new
room was very messy much messier than
999 was allowed to keep its own room any
spilled chocolate milk or smeared
cupcake frosting was either cleaned up
by staff or slurped up by the slime
itself but in this room there was thick
black liquid dripping down all of the
walls some of it arranging itself into
patterns and words though 999 couldn't
read what they said the guards hadn't
noticed the tickle Monster's presence
yet and it kept still excited to give
them a wonderful surprise when they
turned around and saw that it had
followed them inside but they didn't
turn around they were completely focused
on something in front of them what was
it it was a thick glass case that looked
as if it was about to fall apart at any
moment inside there was a mask a
porcelain mask of a frowning face with
that same strange dark fluid dripping
from its eye and mouth holes you know
the procedure right one guard said he
was holding a brand new glass case shiny
and completely empty
of course I do the other scoffed it's my
first time with this anomaly not my
first day on the job just open it up and
take the mask out and put it in here he
tapped on the case he was holding as
quickly as possible yeah I just said I
know the less experienced guard grumbled
don't patronize me he reads towards the
decaying case and prepared to unlock it
wait Did you hear that hear what I
thought I heard never mind
scp-999 vibrated with excitement would
they give it some well-deserved
attention maybe play a game but no the
guard wasn't talking about the eager
orange pal behind him he was feeling the
influence of something much more
Sinister do you want me to do it the
more experience guard offered no just
you really don't hear that that
whispering his colleague just shook his
head
fine it's just been a long week I guess
he sighed and popped the case open
reaching for the mask inside as soon as
his fingers made contact with the
porcelain surface the black goo dripping
onto his skin where he should have been
wearing protective gloves his expression
shifted his eyes went blank like
someone's sleepwalking lost in a dream
even as their body moved in the waking
World Frank what are you waiting for the
other guard nudged him but Frank said
nothing he delicately lifted the mask
out of the glass box and before anyone
could stop him place the frowning white
face over his own only it wasn't
frowning anymore as soon as its features
slipped over Franks covering him erasing
him its mouth curved into a malicious
smile Frank what the hell are you doing
the guard cried out as the man he had
once known grabbed hold of his shoulders
not Frank anymore a voice came out from
behind the ceramic lips but it was
different cruel cold ancient Franks gone
out I'm afraid and he won't be back
anytime soon the guard tried to break
away from the masked man's grasp trying
to reach for the Emergency alarm to
signal that the containment change had
gone horribly wrong but the mask shoved
him into the wall hard the guard hit his
head and slumped to the ground
unconscious and likely concussed well
scp-999 has had just about enough of all
this it hated seeing anyone hurt
especially humans and clearly its help
was sorely needed to make things better
it couldn't tell exactly what had upset
the man in The Mask so much that he was
acting this way but he knew one thing
that always cheered humans up it was
time for a bit of good old-fashioned
tickle wrestling scp-999 hurled itself
across the room enveloping Frank's Body
from his feet to his neck and it began
tickling him as it did the force of
999's tackle sent Frank's Body careening
towards the ground and when it landed
with a heavy thud The Mask flew off his
face and skittered across the floor now
that I could see Frank's face 999 look
for signs of laughter of Joy but Frank
was dead asleep eyes closed jaw slack
his heart was still beating but he
wouldn't wake up confused concerned and
upset at what it had witnessed in this
new room the Slime slithered along the
floor toward the mask that had caused so
much trouble it seemed to be staring at
999 with its dark vacant eyes it didn't
look like a toy in fact it looked like
something that the Slime should avoid
touching but it couldn't help but notice
that the face had changed back to a
frown could 999 really leave the mask
there on the floor frowning like that
the Tickle Monster couldn't help it with
a soft greeting by way of a high-pitched
cooing noise it reached out to the mask
and picked it up though the Slime
creature didn't have a traditional face
for the mask to sit on top of its
influence quickly grabbed hold of 999's
gelatinous frame it stopped moving
stopped gurgling stopped looking at the
world through rose-colored glasses right
now scp-999 was being piloted by the
possessive mask and it was looking for a
way out once it escaped containment he
could find a new host a proper host with
arms legs and a mouth but for now this
undignified vehicle would have to do it
took the mask some time to learn how to
Pilot this strange soft body with its
malleable form and odd methods of moving
itself around the room but it slowly
adjusted and wearing the silhouette of
the Tickle Monster like a disguise oozed
out of its containment room and into the
Hall staff walking by barely even
noticed 999's presence they were too
preoccupied with their work they were
used to seeing it and giving it a polite
nod but most of them didn't have the
time to stop and say a proper hello at
this time of day perhaps this would be
easy after all the mask had lost its
chosen house but found something even
better the perfect cover and the chance
to hide in plain sight it could take in
the lay of the land scope out potential
exit routes and ideally slide out a
foundation custody completely unnoticed
The Mask began to smile at the thought
as the mask steered as CP 999's body
around the site A peculiar feeling began
to nod the back of its mind like an itch
it couldn't quite scratch something
irritating that wouldn't leave it alone
what was that feeling inside of its own
Consciousness The Mask heard a sound a
sweet high-pitched gurgle no that was
impossible and yet somehow the
consciousness of the Tickle Monster had
survived in the face of the mask's power
it was there still needling at the
mask's darkness with that insipid
insistent kindness shut up the mask is
frowning this body belongs to me now why
won't you just die another gurgle this
one even louder more difficult to shut
out did this infernal thing ever shut up
The Mask stopped moving for a moment
concentrating the force of its well it
would drive
scp-9999's mind away and re-establish
dominance just as the mask was grappling
with the influence of scp-999 however a
familiar figure turned on the hall it
was Dr Rhodes from earlier
scp-9999's exuberance bubbled up to the
surface and The Mask couldn't stop its
mouth from flipping back to a smile what
no that was ridiculous and yet the
longer the mask was in contact with the
vibrant orange slime so delighted by
every familiar and unfamiliar face of
encountered it could feel that horrible
positive influence growing stronger and
stronger it was a nauseating warm fuzzy
feeling that just made him want to the
mask let out a giggle then another and
before long it was in the midst of an
absolute giggling fit the mask had
laughed before it had laughed plenty of
times but it was usually a mocking laugh
a cackle Triumph This was a giggle
though of pure joy the sort of sound a
small child makes as they chase a
butterfly through a field this was the
sound of innocence of happiness it was
love Now you listen to me you vile
little worm the mass growled it wasn't
certain if 999 could even understand it
but it had to show this rebellious
creature who was really in charge
release your grip on me I have won you
have lost your form is mind and you
nothing more than a puppet for me to
pull on your strings and use you to my
own ends show some respect and defer to
me the voice of the Slime creature
whimpered in the mask's mind a sound
like a chastised puppy slinking away
with its tail between its legs
that's more like it the mask half Dr
Rhodes looked up from her clipboard and
spotted scp-999 she waved about to greet
the creature when she noticed the
horrible mask perched on top she dropped
her clipboard in shock gasping at the
sight now she breathed heart sinking as
she saw one of the purest pieces of good
in all the foundation fall into the
forces of the Mask that's right the mask
would have puffed out its chest if this
body had a chest to Puff I've taken a
new host do you like my selection it
relished the tearful look in the woman's
eyes the horror that caused her hands to
shake and her cheeks to go pale show me
the way to the exit so I might take my
leave of this place and perhaps I will
spare your life the mask was just
gearing up for a good threat a really
nightmarish one filled with vivid
descriptions of Mutilation and violence
when that disgusting feeling began to
rise up again that warmth that buoyancy
it made the mask want to please don't be
sad here let me give you a hug before it
could stop itself the mask slithered the
tickle Monster's body over to Dr Rhodes
wrapping around her tightly not to hurt
her no to embrace her to comfort her her
horror turned to laughter as the mood
lifting effect of 999's presence began
to work its magic through her laughter
she was also confused why why she
couldn't finish the question but it was
enough to break the mask out of the
spell it reared back horrified at its
actions what have I done what have I
done it slithered quickly down the hall
around the corner away from that woman
who had evoked such fond feelings
towards her no towards all of humanity
The Mask steered its body into a
bathroom coming face to face with a
mirror it stared at Its Reflection its
familiar face and dark eyes dripping
their usual fluid perched atop this
alien thing poisoning its mind what did
you do to me what sort of magic is this
of course 999 did not answer but the
mask could feel its presence could feel
its Delight in the impact it was having
you're ruining me the mask groaned I
strike Terror into Hearts I drive men to
Madness I render their sanity in two way
it trailed off overwhelmed Again by The
Urge to smile to laugh to frolic though
it didn't have a working nose The Mask
could swear it smelled an array of
heavenly scents of fresh roses Breaking
Bad in a stone oven vanilla and lightly
burnt brown sugar it reached for itself
with its pseudo pods about to tear
itself off of the slimy body altogether
but it paused ah very clever I see what
your game is it lowered the pseudopods
brimming with determination you won't
trick me into sparing your life once I
found my freedom and host worthy of me I
will destroy you once and for all but
even as the mask made this declaration
the black liquid seeping from its eyes
and mouth began to change to take on a
lighter appearance was it a trick of the
light no it was it was orange like the
gelatinous Flesh of The Horde creature
it had made the mistake of attaching to
no matter how hard the mask fought the
influence of scp-999 was spreading its
mind raced trying to come up with a new
plan a way to hold on to its identity
but the sound of an alarm blaring
outside the bathroom spurred it to get a
move on once more clearly Dr Rhodes had
alerted someone that the mask had
breached containment time was running
out it needed to find the exit fast it
was now or never The Mask oozed back
into the Hall speeding up as it went
trying desperately to find a way out
before whatever transformation had begun
could complete itself but even as it
struggled it could feel itself changing
warping it burst into Giggles again and
whistled a Happy tune it stopped running
for a moment to wave at an armed guard
and blow them a kiss why had it wanted
to leave this facility in the first
place everyone here was so kind was so
lovely was its best friend no no must
resist must not give into the optimism
to the happiness to the goodness if the
mask had teeth it would have been
clenching them trying to stem the tide
of Joyful noises that threatened to
burst out it felt like something was
tickling it and the tickling just
wouldn't stop stop it the mask dissolved
into Giggles again I mean it it could
feel something coming something big a
loud cracking sound rang out and just as
the guards were closing in on the
possessed Tickle Monster they watched in
awe as cracks spread across the surface
of the possessive mask and all at once
it shattered into pieces the pieces fell
to the floor where they pulled
themselves back together with strands of
black goop meanwhile scp-999 sat there
bouncing with Glee completely unharmed
the Tickle Monster received an extra
special ice cream sundae for its bravery
and amazing work and the mask was
returned to its containment chamber in a
brand new glass case as The Masks
suffered an identity crisis for the
first time in its existence
scp-999 curled up in its pen full of
sugar and gratitude and got some
well-deserved rest there are plenty of
big secrets at the SCP Foundation but
sometimes you've just gotta wonder what
are the smaller Secrets here at SCP
explained we often zoom out to give you
a bird's eye view of the bizarre and
sometimes inexplicable events concerning
a huge number of anomalies but today
we're ditching our telescope in favor of
a microscope to take a look into the
daily life of one very special Blobby
boy
scp-999 the Tickle Monster we took the
liberty of painstakingly stalking
um I mean observing as CP 999 going
about his daily life bringing joy to
everyone around him and not only were
our otherwise cold dead Hearts
thoroughly warmed we were also able to
compile everything we needed to make
this video you're watching right now
welcome one and all to a day in the life
of scp-999 630 a.m rise and shine happy
campers we discover that the Tickle
Monster likes to start his day nice and
early after all the more Daylight you
have out there the easier it is to put
the sunshine in people's hearts so
shortly after waking up
scp-999 uses his little Blobby
pseudopods to put on some pleasant easy
listening music in his containment
chamber delightful he then drinks a
glass of delicious soy milk and helps
himself to a balanced breakfast of
chocolate M M's and a variety of tasty
fruit flavored gummies please note this
is not an acceptable balanced breakfast
for human beings it's important to
remember that scp-9999 has very
different dietary needs to us humans
believe me I tried the scp-999 diet all
I got was severe sugar headaches and
overtime on the toilet but the less said
about that the better after eating his
delicious sugary breakfast the Tickle
Monster grabs a crayon and starts
building his day plan which is normally
filled with a wider array of stimulating
activities every day is a new journey
into excitement for scp-999 this is part
of scp-999 schedule that we very much
recommend you emulate setting your goals
nice and early may help you solidify
your goals nice and early and also help
you feel a warm and fuzzy sense of
accomplishment when the day ends and all
your errands are complete but by the
time all this is done for scp-999 it's
already 8 AM of course while setting
goals for the day ahead is an important
task
scp-9999 and its surprisingly applicable
wisdom also knows the power of
inspiration that's why at around 8 am
the Tickle Monster indulges in his
morning entertainment before any tasks
or cross-tests begin this largely
involves watching cartoons on a
television set provided to him by his
handlers at the SCP Foundation
scp-9999's favorite shows include
SpongeBob SquarePants Blues Clues and
The Backyardigans the foundation is
extremely careful with the programming
that scp-999 is allowed to indulge in
making sure that all the shows are
generally wholesome and sweet with
positive moral messages that one can
carry forward into their day SpongeBob
is a particular favorite for that exact
reason the Tickle Monster sees that
Plucky yellow sponge as a kind of
kindred spirit reminding him to keep a
positive can-do attitude and a sense of
childlike fun after a few episodes of
the show 999 is typically bouncing with
joy and more than feeling SpongeBob's
iconic catchphrase I'm ready and while
it isn't necessarily relevant we'd also
like to state that within the confines
of this metaphor Dr gears's Squidward
moving on 10 a.m now the Tickle Monster
is really ready to take on the day
having filled up on the two essential
Seas of any prosperous day candy and
cartoons he's ready to Slither out there
and make a difference his first order of
business for the workday is sitting in
on the daily site-19 senior researcher
meeting where the top brass of the site
is given a collective debrief on the
day's tasks and given an opportunity to
share any Vital Information of course
morning meetings can be stressful
especially when you work at the SCP
Foundation where your daily task might
be
scp-682 seems particularly cantankerous
today mind paying a visit to his
containment chamber and asking him about
it however scp-999 being there in the
room is kind of like having the ultimate
scented candle he exudes those chill
relaxing Vibes and even the pleasant
smell that puts you in a place of
profound ease the foundation has
discovered that since scp-999 has
started sitting in on the morning
meetings both employee satisfaction and
task completion have increased happy
workers as it turns out are also hard
workers when the meetings end and the
senior researchers are filing out of the
room each one of them gives scp-999 a
little hug or a Pat in hopes of thanking
him for all he does this increases their
emotional well-being as well as
scp-999s it's one of the rare everyone
wins scenarios you'll find at the SCP
Foundation after the meeting scp-999
tends to roam around the site for a
while searching for anyone in need as
you probably already know the Tickle
Monster has an innate sense for when
people are in need of his unique brand
of anomalous positivity if a researcher
or a guard is feeling down
scp-9999 will have an innate sense of
their presence and mercilessly hunt them
down to give them some pep they'll never
forget
allow us to give you a specific example
security officer Dan Richardson was
stressed while he didn't let on to
anyone else working at the foundation
fearing that showing emotion would make
people think less of him his wife was
actually struggling from a severe
illness so when he went into work even
when he was guarding the containment
chambers of truly terrifying monsters
like scp-106 he was only ever worrying
about her nobody else knew except for
scp-999 when the Tickle Monster sends
Dan's distress he slithered over and
began to climb on him unleashing his
rays of anomalous Good Vibes soon enough
Dan felt a kind Freedom he hadn't
experienced since the beginning of his
wife's illness later that day he felt
the courage to visit the site-19
employee mental health counselor at last
and became open about his emotional
struggles it began a long but worthwhile
road to recovery all of which began with
scp-999 and then the Tickle Monster
broke for lunch 12 p.m at around midday
every day
scp-999 slithers on over to the main
site-19 cafeteria to enjoy a wholesome
lunch with Foundation personnel and some
of the other friendly anomalies that do
lunch with them he'll grab a bowl of ice
cream and a colorful Jello pot from the
friendly lunch lady and Slither on over
to the table where scp-073 Kane and
scp-343 God are sitting around chatting
no hard feelings about the whole loud
Market thing right God says biting into
his hamburger it is a process Kane
replies any awkwardness that was there
before immediately evaporated when
scp-999 entered the scene both of these
mysterious anomalies smiled and began
petting him as he cooed and trilled God
levitated the spoon to feed 999 his ice
cream which Kane thought was a little
show-offy but held his tongue because he
was lost in the moment Kane helped 999
peel off the lid to his Jello pot with
his precise mechanical fingers Dr Cliff
who was eating few tables over also
dropped in to give scp-999 a playful pat
on the head and given that Dr clef
typically has the sensibility of an Xbox
360 Call of Duty Lobby this show of
vulnerability was an exceptional act
indeed Dr bright would have done the
same but he was spending lunch in o5
Council detention again because he did
something really stupid again what was
it this time see if you can guess 1 30
PM after lunch scp-999 would spend the
next half an hour having the nature of
his father the terrifying Scarlet King
explained to him for those privy to
certain secret documents you'll know
that scp-999 comes from the most
unlikely of parents the interdimensional
universe destroying monarch of chaos and
evil known as The Scarlet King he was
actually the progeny of the Scarlet
King's seventh bride whose son was
prophesized to one day defeat and
Dethrone the Scarlet King not through
violence and hatred but through love and
kindness so great great it burns out the
Crimson Khan's darkness of course he's
not ready to go toe-to-toe with his
estranged father just yet nor would the
foundation want him to they've made
mistakes in the past by being too
gung-ho and prematurely weaponizing
anomalies under their care just look at
the absolute disaster that unfolded when
they tried to make Abel part of a mobile
task force and he killed all his
foundation comrades when they ran out of
missions to give him that's why they've
decided to take a very different
approach with scp-999 rather than
pushing him too hard too early they've
decided to start drip feeding him the
knowledge piece by piece every day after
lunch some of the more scholarly
researchers have been reading him Choice
extracts from daveite scriptures
concerning the Scarlet King they always
follow it up with a little Rupert the
bear though just so things don't get too
intense 2PM after this unique SCP
Foundation take on story time is done
scp-999 is once again free to roam
around the site dispense joy to whoever
needs it most something you need to
understand about scp-999 is that he's
utterly non-judgmental even a beast of
pure violence and hatred like scp-682 is
considered a potential friend 299 you
may even remember the time that 999 was
able to live up to his name and tickle
the hard to destroy reptile into
submission inducing a hysterical
laughing fit in this otherwise hardcore
Beastie that's why 999 would sometimes
stray into the dark spooky areas of the
site that most people would Fear To
Tread if they weren't specifically
assigned there for starters he nestled
up against the outside of scp-049 the
plague doctors Sal the Sinister surgeon
was feeling a little down in the dumps
due to his continued failure to Stamp
Out the pestilence and the SCP
foundation's stubborn unwillingness to
help him in the task however a loving
visit from the Tickle Monster even on
the other side of a Plexiglas divider
was enough to chase The Blues Away just
when he needed the encouragement most
this strengthened the doctor's resolve
he would continue his research no matter
how many lives it took to perfect his
Curative method admittedly not the best
result of an interaction with scp-999
but 999 was at least happy that the
peculiar beaked man seemed a little less
depressed now at least even if the lack
of depression may lead to a few further
murders down the line who would be next
on scp-9999's rampage of joyfulness and
positive vibes scp-999 like the
benevolent is a friend to all children
so he does what he can to improve the
quality of life for anomalous children
contained by the SCP Foundation as part
of his daily rounds he makes sure to
always visit
scp-053 the young girl as his positivity
Aura is too powerful for the girl's
anomalous ability to passively cause
paranoia and violence to affect him she
often reports having a wonderful time
during their sessions though she wishes
her big dragon friend could come join in
on their tea parties too 4pm by this
time scp-999 is back to roaming again
searching out people or anomalies he can
lend a helping hand to helping people if
you hadn't somehow realized it by now is
one of 999's greatest joy in life that's
why when slithering near the high
security humanoid containment wing and
seeing groups of researchers running for
the hills he got the sense that perhaps
he was needed here and decided to
investigate further as all the
researchers ran screaming in One
Direction
scp-999 slithered audaciously in the
other he heard one of the researchers
yelling the old man got out sound the
alarm and run for your lives of course
this did nothing to deter scp-9999 even
as the Containment Breach Sirens blasted
through the air around him 999 didn't
fear death he only feared failure
failure in the task to make everyone
around him as happy as possible up to
and including some of the most horrific
and depraved monsters SCP Foundation has
ever contained very much including the
Monstrous creature coming towards him
down the hall the old man
scp-106 gave a throaty chuckle as he
shuffled down the tiles his black goo
fizzling on the ground with one hand he
traced his fingertips along the wall
spreading corruption that ate away at
the wall like a cancer with the other
hand he dragged a rapidly melting corpse
that had once been a hapless researcher
standing too close to the wall of 106's
containment chamber now the old man was
eager to cause more pain and havoc in
the rest of the facility before he was
forced back into containment until he
ran into scp-999 coming towards him in
the hallway suddenly 106 felt something
change in his mind his typically sharp
predatory sadistic thoughts suddenly
felt odd and fuzzy almost formless it
was almost like he'd been hit by some
kind of anomalous chloroform that dulled
the edge of his evil and then he
laughing why because this strange Blobby
creature had crawled up onto his body
and begun to tickle him relentlessly it
didn't make sense how come this creature
wasn't affected by his corrosive mucus
but it was already too late he was
doubled over onto the floor cackling and
unlucky for the old man but luckily for
everyone else it was enough to pacify
him until a mobile task force with high
intensity lights showed up and Shepherd
him back into containment it was a truly
humiliating defeat for scp-106 but at
the same time he'd be churlished to deny
that he had somewhat of a good time 7 PM
as we get deeper into the evening
scp-999 still has plenty to do after all
every day that ends at the SCP
Foundation also Heralds the end of many
people's lives and that's on a good day
too needless to say there would always
be plenty of people who needed cheering
up at the end of each day and nobody was
more up to the task than the Tickle
Monster first as CP 999 decided to make
its way down to the site-19 medical Bay
to treat everyone who'd experienced
varying degrees of horrific injury from
a typical day's work at the foundation
some were horrifically burned others
were missing parts some were pretty much
catatonic with the mental trauma of the
things they'd seen many had distinctive
fresh wounds that could only come from
scp-682's massive Claws and fangs it was
a powerful Wellspring of misery
scp-999 slithered from bed to bed
nuzzling up to the different patients of
the medical Bay and lifting their moods
you'd be amazed at the medicinal
benefits of a positive mindset and he's
one of the few Medical Treatments that
won't utterly destroy you if you don't
have insurance after helping the injured
scp-9999 decided to visit the d-class
barracks While most of the SCP
Foundation looked down on the lowly D
classes especially given the criminal
history of many of them
scp-999 held no such prejudices he
sensed that the people in the the
barracks were confused and scared for
their safety and that was enough for him
to get in there and help he slithered to
the gangway observing that some of the
bunk beds were empty from the days less
stressful tests these hardened criminals
many of which were literal murderers
immediately felt themselves softening in
the presence of this cheerful Blobby
creature for the first time in many of
their long difficult and tragic lives
they dared to believe that perhaps
everything might be okay sometime in the
not so distant future and scp-999
couldn't be happier about that 9 30 PM
as the night winds down one of the
researchers assigned to scp-999 reads
him a bedtime story to help him wind
down after an exciting day
scp-999 tries not to go to bed too late
at night knowing that in early bedtime
and an early rise ensure health and
energy whale song and white noise is
played over a small radio while scp-999
settles down to sleep ready to have only
the sweetest dreams so ends another
wonderful day and there you have it
folks a day in the life of the endlessly
adorable scp-999 is there anything from
the tickle Monster's daily routine that
you think you might start incorporating
into your own day-to-day lives let us
know down in the comments personally in
a world that can sometimes be cold and
cruel we think having the strength to be
a little Kinder and smile a little
brighter can make a far bigger
difference to some people than you'll
ever understand and nobody exemplifies
that better than
scp-999 Panic had set in researchers
were frantic there was a buzz of
activity not born of excitement but from
sheer widespread Fear The Scarlet King
was coming nobody at the foundation knew
when or even how the Monstrous
multiversal Tyrant would spring free and
bring endless chaos with him but
everyone knew it would be soon they'd
all had the same warning the same night
in fact it wasn't just the foundation
either but the entire world had shivered
in their sleep sharing in the bad dream
of the destruction that was yet to come
the Personnel of the SCP Foundation were
on high alert of course the organization
had been aware of the impending threat
of the Scarlet King for longer than
almost anyone else but that was part of
the problem through some anomalous dream
had by everyone on earth now everyone
else knew the foundation was less
interested in uncovering the source of
the Nightmare and more trying to
counteract its potential side effects
that was what potentially offered the
Scarlet King the power he needed to
enter into reality after all the more
people knew about him tried to
understand or to find the Eldritch
entity the more power he was able to
obtain we have an army one member of
personnel chimed in during a frantic
debate we have an almost unlimited
fighting force that are specially
trained to handle anomalous threats the
MTF are you crazy another argued the the
mtfs are certainly not unlimited at any
rate the Scarlet King might be one of
the most powerful beings in the entire
Multiverse how can our troops even our
anomalous units even hope to stand
against that you're proposing sending
our people into a Slaughter they'd all
be wiped out in the moment one of the
other researchers concurred we need to
be focusing our efforts on the amnestic
rollout if we can distribute enough to
the population we can wipe their
Collective memories of the dream from
the other night they'll forget and that
should slow the approach of the Scarlet
King slow maybe but it will
but it won't retorted
our best option even now while we try to
come up with a strategy that could be
enough to draw him in we're willing him
into existence as we speak uh what about
deploying another SCP came a voice from
the edge of the group it belonged to
Junior researcher Jake Harrison a
relatively new member of the foundation
who had been reading up on files related
to The Scarlet King he knew that in
trying to understand and come up with a
way to best the murderous multiversal
warlord that he was inadvertently
feeding him power but Jake seemed to
have stumbled on the one solution that
everyone else had overlooked there was
already another anomaly that might have
been perfectly suited for defeating the
Scarlet King what do you suggest
Harrison one of the other researchers
that you really think something like 682
would be willing to work with us and
destroy the Scarlet king that's absurd I
heard 682 is meant to be one of the
Scarlet King's Children another remark
no not 682 Jake argued turning to the
researcher that had just made a comment
about the entity's supposed children a
group of anomalies that we believe to
have been born of the skull King himself
but you're on the right track we use
scp-999 the group of researchers looked
dumbfounded at Jake he couldn't tell if
they were about to yell at him or they
would all burst out laughing to his
surprise they actually looked to be
considering his proposal it was widely
believed that scp-999 the adorable blob
of orange slime known as the Tickle
Monster was actually the final child of
the Scarlet king that's not entirely
implausible one of the researchers
answered scp-999 is believed to be an
Ultimate Force for good that could in
theory defeat his father ah the Scarlet
King is meant to be unparalleled chaos
the two could cancel each other out
another theorized but the Tickle Monster
sorry
scp-9999 it's an infant a child someone
else pointed out even if it could one
day beat the sky solid King it's nowhere
near strong enough to yet we might have
days minutes even before he arrives and
I don't know if 999 has the power to
stop his father then what if we could
make him stronger Jake replied a risky
idea brewing in his head surely you
aren't suggesting suddenly a loud
rumbling rang out like an earthquake
only much louder and instead of coming
from the ground below the noise was
coming from the sky the foundation's
researchers raced in the nearest window
or ran out of the buildings they were in
to turn their gazes upward scored across
the sky above was a deep blood red crack
a wound in the fabric of reality itself
it was huge almost covering one horizon
to the next and everyone looking at it
knew what it meant that crack in the sky
heralded the approach of the Scarlet
King Junior researcher Harrison spent
the next hour impatiently trying to get
a hold of someone anyone who could
approve his proposal the o5 council were
already swamped with suggestions for how
to stop the Scarlet King each one
contributing to his rapid approach
eventually Jake made it through and
spoke directly with a representative an
underling for the o5 council listen to
me he urged I know this isn't your
department but I need someone to sign
off on this please the lives of everyone
in this reality could depend on it what
are you proposing the Clockworks scp-914
J cancer we place scp-999 inside speed
up the process and make him strong
enough to stop the Scarlet King it was
an astronomical gamble using the
anomalous Improvement machine
constructed of a multitude of clockwork
components cogs Gyros gears scp-914 was
a device that could be used to enhance
or refine any object placed inside its
input Booth depending on the setting
items could be transformed destroyed or
vastly improved using the Clockworks
rough setting disintegrated to any test
subject while cores dismantled it to its
base components one-to-one replaced any
item with an almost identical copy then
there were the fine and very fine
settings the former would cause 914 to
improve any item and the later capable
of the same but with one key difference
very fine would refine an object even
more usually by giving it anomalous
properties Jake had read up on scp-914
and knew that the foundation had
permitted researchers to conduct tests
using the machine however following a
catastrophic test nothing organic could
be tested in scp-914 that was a strict
rule no biological organism or living
thing of any description was to be
placed within the Clockworks it was
Jake's hope however that desperate times
called for desperate measures surely
with the Scarlet King almost upon them
the council would waive the restriction
and allow scp-999 to undergo refinement
the o5 council representative zoys cut
out after Jake made his suggestion there
was a long pause even without the
pressure of incoming Calamity the
silence seemed to extend for a painfully
long time suddenly someone else spoke up
in their place a modulated distorted
voice it quickly became clear to Jake
that he was talking directly to a member
of the o5 council under a different set
of circumstances he might have felt
honored but right now it was almost as
scary as the threat of Destruction by
the Scarlet King listen closely Junior
researcher the council member said on
the other end of the Comm line you may
think you understand as cp914 you may
even think that it might Aid Us in
stopping the current crisis but you are
far far mistaken you will cease this
current course of action immediately
your proposal has been denied but wait
Jake protested surely it could work I
know biological material wasn't
permitted inside the Clockworks but that
doesn't mean it can't affect living
matter scp-999 is a living organism if
he really is everything we think he is
and we just put him through the refining
process he could nove researcher
Harrison the voice part using the
Clockworks would mean we risk losing 9
nine nine what are you talking about you
appear to have a fundamental
misunderstanding of scp-914 Junior
researcher the council member chastised
it doesn't merely improve upon existing
objects but replaces them with a new
version it creates if we were to place
999 inside the creature as we know it
would be gone forever and if it really
is capable of stopping this catastrophe
we will then have lost our Ultimate
Weapon against the Scarlet King but Jake
trying to say enough every second we
waste discussing our options the more
power the Scarlet King is able to amass
so why don't we stop talking and
actually do something the young
researchers shouted giving in to his
frustration and losing his temper the
calm line went dead there was no one on
the other end anymore another rumbling
sound rippled through the building even
louder than the last Tremor Jake ran
towards a nearby window and looked out
in horror it was already too late the
red crack above had split open wider and
like a tidal wave hordes of nightmarish
creatures came spilling out raining down
on the world and commanding them sending
forth his minions in a flood of
Destruction was the Scarlet King himself
Jake was done waiting for permission
from the council he sprinted as fast as
he could through the facility past Panic
researchers fleeing for their lives
while security officers and MTF troops
abandoned their posts in the futile hope
they could survive the end of this
reality and all others Jake forced
himself not to pay attention he needed
to find scp-999 the playful blob was
often free to roam around the facility
improving the days of anyone it
encountered so all Jake needed to do was
find anyone who seemed happy despite the
catastrophe and scp-999 wouldn't be so
far away outside the world began to
resemble the nightmare that everyone had
experienced the night before cities were
burning as monstrous Abominations tore
through innocent civilians and ripped
buildings and cars to Trends reducing
every nearby standing structure to
little more than Rubble with frightening
speed and ease the Scarlet King and his
armies had been waiting for this moment
for centuries Millennia eons even and
now nothing could stop them from
unfueling Pure indulgent Chaos on this
reality they had their work cut out for
them subjugating and destroying the
entire Multiverse but that isn't to say
they weren't enjoying it people across
the Earth were being killed in droves in
the name of the Scarlet King he diverted
a significant portion of his forces to
attacking the SCP Foundation itself
while the boots on the ground MTF troops
the ones that had remained loyal were
usually a formidable fight they were no
match for the Eldritch armies of the
Scarlet King The Horde began to set free
other anomalies kept locked up in
containment either by accident when they
stormed the foundation facilities or
intentionally seeking out their cells to
Spring them some scps tried to stand up
to the scrod King and fight back back
the likes of the plague doctor the
Specter and scp-2800 all tried their
best to ward off the oncoming attacks of
the Scarlet King's foot soldiers they
lasted longer than those who decided
instead to run away turning heel and
trying in vain to escape the destructive
reach of the Scarlet King even anomalies
like scp-106 who could escape to other
planes of existence or pocket Dimensions
weren't safe in hiding they were only
prolonging the inevitable the Scarlet
king would find them all no corner of
the Multiverse was safe and of course
some scps thrived in the catastrophe
creatures like scp-682 the infamous hard
to destroy reptile found themselves free
to exact revenge on the foundation and
Humanity at large of these not all the
anomalies gave away their allegiance 682
in particular was too busy killing
anything and came into contact with
whether they were human or part of the
Scarlet King's Army but other scps
gladly saw more fealty with the Crimson
Cosmic conqueror forming alliances with
the entity responsible for setting them
loose and joining the mass of
monstrosities he had Unleashed and yet
in the midst of all the chaos the
Calamity and the millions upon millions
of deaths one Junior SCP Foundation
researcher was still searching for the
wholesome orange blob Jake Harrison had
put all his chips on scp-999 and
eventually tracked the Tickle Monster
down the building around him was
crumbling attacks from the Scarlet King
and his minions bombarding every second
as Jake ran into the mess hall his eyes
instantly caught sight of the ball of
orange slime cowering under a table hey
hey he whispered hoping to coax it out
it's okay I know there's a lot going on
right now hell it's the end of the world
outside but if you come with me I think
we can fix it together come on little
guy what do you say as if in reply 999
immediately leaped up out of its Hiding
Place Jake caught it in his arms
instantly feeling a wave of bomb wash
over him thanks to the tickle Monster's
calming anomalous effect he tried to
stop himself from fully succumbing to
the Good Vibes that the gelatinous
creature provided after all he still had
a job to do and time was short the
Scarlet King and his invading Army might
have seen for the most part to be
indulging in wonton destruction
decimating cities and Foundation sites
killing humans left right and center but
Jake figured that if there was any
method to their Madness then scp-999
would be at the very center of it not
even the Scarlet King knew for certain
if scp-999 really was his offspring
maybe he had heard the rumors and wanted
to reach the Tickle Monster just before
it had a chance to stop him if it even
could if the Scarlet King believed even
for a second that his supposed son stood
a chance at defeating him and ending his
reign of terror then he'd waste no time
hunting the orange blob down his army of
nightmarish creatures would comb every
corner of the world until they found
scp-9 99 although they might not think
to look inside the Clockworks placing
the smiling slimy SCP on the input Booth
Jake fiddled with the controls for
scp-914 he never performed any
experiments using the machine before but
it was all pretty self-explanatory
throwing the dial to very fine he gave a
moment's pause looking at the adorable
anomaly in the machine the warning from
the council rang in his ears if he
activated the Clockworks he'd in effect
be killing scp-999 either that or the
Scarlet king would do it himself when he
found the Tickle Monster neither
scenario ended well then the Thundering
sounds of the massacre outside got
louder screams coming from innocent
people who were being caught in the
Scarlet King's Carnage there was no
question about it if what Jake was about
to do really could stop all this Mayhem
then it was worth replacing as CP 999 to
do it with a deep breath he flipped the
switch the clicking and clacking of the
Clockworks component's word into life
were drowned out by the approaching
Tremors something was coming no he was
coming Jake thought the very fabric of
the building around him started shaking
brickwork and cement crumbling and
falling apart as a large hand fingers
ending and pointed Crimson claws
wrenched open the roof with ease looking
up in horror Jake saw that the sky was a
dark shade of red towering over it a
colossal crimson-clad Warrior looked in
on the frightened researcher horns
protruding from its head maybe because
scp-999 was still nearby The Blob was
offering him some kind of positive
mental protection otherwise the mere
side of the gigantic monstrous being
above him would have driven Jake and any
other Mortal mad the Scarlet King was
upon him
came a booming voice that sounded like
hundreds of Screams overlaying each
other the Scarlet King's gaze seemed to
shift slightly turning from Jake as he
lay helplessly on the ground to look at
scp-914 the machine had fully activated
and couldn't be stopped now either
through foreknowledge or some kind of
cosmic sense the Eldritch monstrosity
seemed to know exactly what the device
did
what have you done
the Scarlet King roared he raised a
gargantuan Fist and brought it straight
down through the air towards Jake he
couldn't run the Scarlet King was so
vast in size that there was no way the
researcher would be able to evade the
oncoming strike Jake raised his arms in
a futile attempt to protect himself
despite knowing that the Scarlet King's
fist would likely plunge through the
very surface of the Earth Below but then
again maybe the junior researcher just
didn't want to watch there was a pause
the strike never came it was only when
Jake built up the courage to open his
eyes that he saw what had happened a
long tendril of orange slime had reached
out of scp-914 forming a protective
barrier between Jake and The Scarlet
King suddenly with all the force of a
tidal wave the newly refined scp-9999
came pouring out of the Clockworks the
tickle Monster's Mass had increased it
was thousands if not millions of times
bigger swept aside and out of Harm's Way
by the orange slime the junior
researcher looked up in amazement at as
scp-999 reached up into the sky able to
look its supposed to face the Scarlet
King recoiled in horror as the Tickle
Monster engulfed him pulling the cosmic
Crimson plunderer into an Embrace as
they hugged there seemed to be a change
in the Scarlet King the Eldritch monster
had spent all his time since the dawn of
creation as a cruel nihilistic conqueror
he had killed and enslaved devoured
ancient gods and slaughtered entire
planes of existence in his quest to
annihilate everything but now held tight
by his gelatinous son his heart shifted
it was as if the Scarlet King's eyes had
been opened and he could see the beauty
of creation the sheer overwhelming
goodness of scp-9999 enhanced by scp-914
undid the evil of the Scarlet King
himself only it didn't stop as the
orange slime engulfed the Scarlet King
in a hug he began to be unmade the
Tickle Monster without even trying to
harm father had been made into such a
beacon of pure positivity by the
Clockworks that the Scarlet King simply
ceased to exist he was unwoven not
killed but rendered without any purpose
he barely even felt any pain but at the
same time was removed from this and
every other universe and still it didn't
stop the newly recreated scp-999 spread
across the world like an orange flood
the Scarlet King's armies the other scps
even the few surviving human beings were
all wiped away
scp-999 spread to every corner of the
Earth turning the Blue Planet Orange as
he coded it purging every single scrap
of negativity all hatred all cruelty all
evil even that of the SCP Foundation
itself the entire world was unmade by
the Tickle Monster not out of malice but
so that nobody anywhere could cause the
Scarlet King to re-emerge at the same
time all that was left was a
planet-sized ball of orange slime lonely
spinning through space
robed figures with hidden faces stand
over seven young women tied up the robed
figures chant phrases both Arcane and
profane the leader amongst these dark
cultists clears his Wicked throat and
says Be not Afraid girls you are here
for something wonderful do we get seven
perfect children for the Scarlet King
how did we get here and more importantly
what happened afterward in the near
constant darkness that follows the Grim
but necessary work of the SCP Foundation
there is one bright light that can
always be counted on to keep hope alive
to bring a little sunshine into
everyone's days
scp-999 the Tickle Monster the sweet
simple creature does nothing but provide
an endless source of Joy hugging playing
and delighting and loving everything
around it but what if I told you that
this slimy little friend has hidden
depths a tragic history that seems
impossible to reconcile with the happy
playful B being we all know and love how
could 999 the happiest SCP ever have a
sad backstory while it's one of the best
kept secrets at the foundation before we
get to that let's talk about a
foundation researcher and her brand new
job a new job that would make her privy
to some highly classified Foundation
Secrets Dr Izzy Collingwood was
delighted to wake up to a call informing
her that she had been appointed to one
of the most coveted positions at the SCP
Foundation after applying Crossing her
fingers and hoping for the best she had
been promoted to head researcher for
scp-999 what could be better than
attending to the kindest gentlest cutest
anomaly in Foundation custody gone were
the days of coming into work and
wondering if she'd leave in one piece no
more cleaning up toxic spills fighting
to contain killer creatures or fetching
cups of coffee for old doctors that
wouldn't give her so much as a thank you
years of hard work had paid off now she
could rest on her Laurels and do work
that she truly enjoyed there was just a
matter of some simple paperwork and she
would be ready to begin this extremely
welcome new chapter of her professional
life when she walked into her office to
get started on the paperwork something
unusual caught her eye there was a small
stack of files on her desk with a sticky
note attached to the front there were
just two words written on the note to
indicate what might await her inside the
folders the truth she scoffed at first
very funny guys she called out the door
but no one responded no one came forward
to take credit for the elaborate joke
maybe they were playing the long game or
maybe she couldn't be sure she sat down
flipping the first folder open it was
Untitled unlabeled just plain text on a
page she almost closed it after a brief
scan but the words the Scarlet King
jumped out at her she had worked at the
foundation long enough to hear that name
more than a few times often spoken in
tones as if merely speaking his name
would bring about some kind of disaster
as she dug deeper into the file she
realized just what she was looking at
the proposed origins of the Scarlet King
himself it was a folkloric explanation
one her scientific mind struggled to
wrap around but she had seen so many
strange things over the years things
that defied all rational explanation
perhaps there was some truth to be found
in the myths the Scarlet King had
according to the file once been an elder
god born from the earliest days of
existence in the shadows of the tree of
knowledge he had devoured his brothers
and sisters growing stronger with each
one he consumed as his strength
increased so too did his overwhelming
pain and hate his deep desire to destroy
the tree of knowledge and all living
creatures he declared himself the king
of darkness and through a series of
horrific events took seven unwilling
brides and bound to him with magical
seals each bride bore Supernatural
children powerful terrible and monstrous
the first bride actpik had only a few
children those few were skilled
strategists exceptionally wise in the
ways of war the second bride was icor
overcome with constant Despair and
desolation her children conquered with
massive unthinking armies never sated
and never quelled the third bride
aristot hated her sisters and all she
surveyed the fourth bride azib took the
shape of a great Beast her children
followed in her Steed and were
invulnerable their thick hides
impenetrable by physical or magical
means the fifth bride was unhut blessed
with a strong mind and cursed with a
fragile body her children were gifted in
the ways of magic and Incredibly
destructive the sixth bride atilif would
not speak she kept to herself and like
her her children moved in silent Islands
disguising themselves as whatever they
wished the seventh bride however was
different ahabat was her name the
smallest of the seven with an unbroken
Spirit she birthed Mighty Heroes that
she trained in secret in hopes that one
day they would overcome her family's
darkness and topple the king from his
throne all the while the Scarlet King
wages his Unholy war against all things
waiting for the day he can arrive in our
realm and unleash absolute destruction
Dr Collingwood shuddered as she finished
reading an undeniable chill passing over
her this definitely wasn't some kind of
prank or hazing ritual this was
something dark something real she held
secrets in her hands and she couldn't
stop reading them now she opened the
next folder it was a description of a
cult monitored and raided by the SCP
Foundation called the children of the
Scarlet King also known as group Mendes
during a 16-month investigation of
Vietnam homeless religious group the
foundation's undercover operatives were
able to ascertain a great deal of
pertinent information on the group what
they found was troubling and of great
concern the group had ties to several
wealthy benefactors as well as links to
extremist paranormal groups their set of
beliefs was relatively simple and
disturbing they worshiped the Scarlet
King and were devoted to supporting him
in his battle to destroy the Earth and
all Life As We Knew It the faithful who
followed him in this task would be
rewarded handsomely with positions of
power in this new hellish World an
initial estimate put the cult's
membership at approximately 8 000
members a quarter of whom belonged to
the group's primary branch in Alabama
the reporting on the cult was detailed
far too dense and heavily researched to
be fake again she had the distinct
feeling that someone was trying to tip
her off about something the foundation
hadn't wanted to be widespread knowledge
with shaky hands she picked up the final
file what awaited her inside there was
only one way to find out she flipped it
open and began to read it was a file on
an entity known as scp-231 specifically
scp-231-7 an addendum was attached to
the beginning of the file reading all
Personnel assigned to
scp-231-7 must rotate out for one month
of psychological counseling after two
months on site
scp-231-7 is to be kept at an
undisclosed location all Personnel
assigned to scp-231 will be transported
there blindfolded from site 19 by Route
including no fewer than seven different
forms of transportation including but
not limited to aircraft automobile
underground tunnel and several we cannot
discuss here removal of the blindfold
during the transport process is grounds
for immediate termination Personnel
assigned to
scp-231-7 must undergo heavy
psychological testing before being
cleared to enter enter the site
individuals must score at least 72
points on the Milgram obedience
examination be unmarried have no
Offspring and express nothing less than
total loyalty to the foundation normal
psychological screening procedures
against access to disorders are waived
so long as the class-d Personnel in
question has the mental capacity to
carry out procedure 110 Montauk as
needed Personnel who Express sympathy
towards
scp-231-7s plight and or Express a
desire to rescue or sympathize towards
scp-231-7 will be transferred to another
project without delay any actual rescue
attempts will be met with immediate
termination Personnel who have served on
the staff of
scp-231-7's containment team are not
required to divulge that information to
others no official record shall be kept
in the names of any staff assigned to
scp-231-7 nor will said service appear
in the Personnel files of said staff
while on site individuals assigned to a
CPT 231-7 will be issued concealing
helmets with integrated voice changers
to protect their identity on-site staff
are not to remove said uniforms in the
presence of other staff members off-duty
hours are to be spent in private
quarters Alone six class D Personnel are
to be assigned to
scp-231-7 each month for the purposes of
carrying out procedure 110 Montauk
violent criminals are not to be used for
this purpose due to the possibility of
accidental fatality during the 110
Montauk process Dr Collingwood swallowed
the lump of dread in her throat her
Palms beginning to sweat
scp-231-7 was a young woman retrieved
during a police raid on a warehouse
owned by the children of the Scarlet
King she was one of seven women found
there the first of which went into labor
24 hours after being rescued she did not
give birth to an ordinary child however
she gave birth to a monster that took
the lives of dozens of civilians she did
not survive the birth the second woman
was lost shortly after also succumbing
to the dangers of the creature waiting
to be born from her womb one by one the
survivors the women chosen by this cult
to become the new bride of the Scarlet
King fell soon enough there was only one
left
scp-231-7 kept contained at a foundation
site in a hospital bed that she could
never leave Dr collingwood's stomach
churned as horrible images flooded her
mind the notes from attending
researchers in scp-231's file insisted
they were doing all they could to save
the woman to free her from her fate but
that there was little they could do each
birth opened a Gateway from this world
to another to a world of darkness and
despair and they could not allow the
final seal to be broken simply putting
the woman out of her misery would cause
the effect to jump to a new host a new
bride there was nothing to be done the
file fell from Dr collingwood's hand as
she pushed herself to her feet running
out into the hallway who put these on my
desk she shouted her voice echoing down
the empty Hall well what do you want
from me but no answer came slowly she
returned to her office and sank down
into her chair haunted by what she had
read she had seen horrific things in her
time at the foundation but nothing that
had shaken her to her core quite like
this the silence in Dr collingwood's
office was broken by the sound of a
tinny beep coming from her computer she
turned on the screen and saw the source
of the alert one new message from o5
command what could they possibly have to
say to her could it have something to do
with the files that had wound up on her
desk she accepted the message quickly
completed the mandatory multimodal
biometric ID scan and began to read
hello Dr Collingwood and congratulations
on your new appointment as
scp-9999's head researcher one of the
cushiest and most enviable assignments
in the entire Foundation
scp-999 is one of the few anomalies in
our custody who will not only never
attempt to harm you but will actively
try to save your life if you're ever in
danger though your initial reaction when
receiving this assignment was no doubt
Elation you may have thought it was odd
that such a seemingly low risk position
was assigned by the o5 council directly
if you had already heard rumors of this
prior to your assignment you probably
thought it was mere nepotism the o5s
protecting their friends and loved ones
by giving them the safest job possible
Dr Collingwood sat back in her chair
laughing to herself and shaking her head
she would never admit it but she
absolutely had heard those rumors even
believe them until it happened to her
unless you are so narcissistic to think
that someone on the o5 council must be
your secret admirer you've likely
realized that this is not the case to
understand why this is our concern you
need to know about
scp-9999's Origins you may have noticed
that its file makes no mention of where
it was discovered this is a deliberate
Mission if you are not familiar with the
mythology of the Scarlet King I suggest
you read up on him there's plenty of
unclassified information on him in the
foundation database all that's relevant
for now is that he is to the best of our
knowledge the most powerful malevolent
entity in the Multiverse her stomach
dropped At The Mention Of The Scarlet
King she was right this was all
connected somehow she leaned forward
eyes starting across the words with
increasing intensity as she read on
you've been with us since you were a
research assistant Dr Collingwood in
that time I assume you've heard many
rumors about some of the horrific things
we do here at the foundation that you've
probably never personally witnessed I
regret to inform you that these rumors
are true or at least they were a
pharmaturgical cult calling itself the
children of the Scarlet King enacted a
ritual wherein seven young girls became
Effigies for each of the Scarlet King's
Seven Brides allowing them to bear his
horrid Offspring how they obtain gain
the knowledge to perform this ritual is
unclear since all we ever recovered were
handwritten notebooks superficial
resemblances to some psychic practices
has led to some speculate that the
children of the Scarlet King may have
some ties to Modern soccer Cults it is
an interesting idea but no concrete
evidence has ever been found to link the
two investigation into the matter is
ongoing as for the ritual itself each
birth caused more destruction than the
last the writings of the cult's priest
predicted nothing less than the
apocalypse if the seventh bride gave
birth which could only be prevented if
procedure 110 Montauk was performed
without fail each and every day to our
seemingly great Fortune The Notebook
contained detailed instructions on how
110 Montauk was to be carried out
needless to say we found this
suspiciously convenient why would they
devise counter measures to prevent the
very apocalypse they were trying to
invoke we needed more in information
regarding these entities fortunately our
archaeologists have Unearthed numerous
tablets Scrolls and artifacts on the
ancient Davos they were a sadistic and
warmongering people who were granted
Unholy power and knowledge by the
Scarlet King as a result for the death
and suffering they caused one of the
David tablets in our possession found
covered in dust and blood was a theogony
for the Scarlet King and his Brides it
was quite informative the information
that we found most relevant to our
situation was that the seventh bride was
not like her sisters she was never
completely broken by her King's
subjugation instead of monsters she gave
birth to Great heroes in the hopes that
they would destroy her sister's children
and overthrow their father thus far all
have failed but by a vote of seven in
favor six against admittedly more out of
concern for procedure 110 montauk's lack
of viability as a long term containment
strategy than out of empathy for the
girl the o5 council decided to believe
that the seventh bride still remained
unbroken and that her child would be an
asset to us at the risk of causing an XK
Class end of the world scenario
scp-231-7 was relieved from procedure
110 Montauk following the deaths of
scp-231-16 and was allowed to give birth
scp-999 was the result Dr Collingwood
gasped her hand flying to her mouth a
research assistant walking by her office
paused looked at her curiously through
the window she waved them off with a
forced smile and turned back to the
screen surely she couldn't have read
that correctly but no there it was plain
as can be go ahead and read that again
be sure you understand it in all its
Preposterous Ridiculousness the Tickle
Monster is the child of the Scarlet King
we've been running a
counter-intelligence campaign ever since
which is why everyone and their mother
thinks we've still got a girl strapped
to a rack in a bunker somewhere let them
think that far better for everyone that
the children of the Scarlet King believe
that they're playing us for fools than
for them to know that there is a threat
to their King the girl herself is fine
by the way she was cured of the trauma
from her ordealed buying scp-999 at
which point it was decided she could be
returned to her family so long as they
were all given class F and nestics
implanted with new identities and
relocated to a town at least 1 000
kilometers away from the children of the
Scarlet King's nearest known activity on
the insistence of the Ethics Committee
the family was also given a seven-figure
payout as compensation for our repeated
misdeeds against their daughter as well
as the families of the other
scp-231s I suppose it was technically
malpractice on our part in case we have
any moles for the children of the
Scarlet King in the foundation as far as
anyone else knows 231-7's Family were
killed in front of her as part of 110
Montauk I'm sure you're skeptical are we
insane how could our sweet little Tickle
Monster ever hope to Dethrone a
lovecraftian horror of unparalleled
might well scp-999 is less than a decade
old it is still just a child and nowhere
near its full strength even so its power
is incredible even brief interaction
with scp-999 can permanently cure severe
depression and PTSD and more recent
experiments have resulted in the
complete Reformation of d-class
personnel who were previously
unrepentant sociopaths this effect is
not chemical but psychic and one day it
may grow powerful enough that not even
the Scarlet King himself will be immune
the experiment with scp-682 was most
remarkable based on multiple daveite
texts including descriptions from
scp-140 itself we are reasonably certain
that 60 82 is The Offspring of the
fourth Scarlet bride if this is true
then scp-999 is already strong enough to
temporarily quell the malevolence of its
own Eldritch siblings one day 999 could
very well be strong enough to
permanently reform its family members
just as it reforms human beings it will
not overthrow the Scarlet King by force
but with light and love and laughter
that can brighten the blackest of Hearts
999 is not in reality a safe class SCP
it is famul it is the best and really
the only weapon we have against some of
the most powerful hostile entities known
to exist by all means doctor enjoy the
relative safety of your new position but
do keep in mind that scp-999 is not a
mere pet that we fancy it is one of our
most valuable assets and must be
safeguarded at all costs its safety and
well-being are Paramount and you are not
at Liberty to share this information to
anyone without level 5 5 or 999 security
clearance as per protocol an authorized
disclosure of level 5 classified
information will result in your
termination this email will
automatically delete as soon as you
leave the terminal so feel free to
reread it as many times as necessary to
remember all the pertinent information
take good care of our little Tickle
Monster the fate of the Multiverse May
well depend on it your secret admirer if
anyone asks 05-1 Dr Collingwood let out
a long slow breath as her mind did its
best to process everything she just read
the message looked official and when she
really thought about it this all made a
twisted kind of sense what could scp-999
possibly be if not some sort of Mythic
hero of divine prophecy what other
explanation could there be for something
so utterly perfectly good maybe one day
that happy little orange slime would
save them all and do it with a smile but
for now it was just a little innocent
child no need to burden with talk of
heroism of epic battles between good and
evil for now she would just pour scp-999
a heaping bowl of M Ms give it a gentle
pet and say thank you the Tickle Monster
gurgled excitedly in response nuzzling
his new head researcher's hand he didn't
understand what she was thanking him for
but he appreciated it all the same chaos
had erupted all hell had broken loose
and Nightmares were running amok even
from her perspective watching as fleshy
Abominations tore through the streets of
New York City Eliza Flynn couldn't
escape the feeling that the entire world
had gone mad only moments before things
had been calm normal another mundane
uninteresting day in the Big Apple now
she was watching in horror from
underneath an overturned table as a
group of things had seemingly appeared
out of nowhere unbeknownst to Eliza
these creatures were instances of
something no known as scp-610
alternatively going by the name the
flesh that hates from her hiding place
inside the local coffee shop she
frequented they looked like horrific
mutated masses of Flesh that barely
resembled anything even close to human
but that's what they were or at least
had been Eliza had witnessed a barista
rushing out into the street trying to
get away from a group of scp-610s that
were bashing their appendages against
the front window in trying to make a
break for it the mutated creatures
attacked the Barista killing him upon
making contact with his skin it was only
a short while afterwards that Eliza
spotted his body moving the Infectious
process only accelerated by the heat
from a nearby car that was on fire
before long what had once been a barista
an ordinary person was now another of
the grotesque flesh monsters Mike she
remembered his name had been Mike she'd
read it on his name tag when she came
women for her morning coffee he had
always smiled never got the spelling of
her name right on her to-go cup writing
it with an S instead of a z and now he
was gone worse than dead he wasn't even
Mike anymore instead turned into another
scp-610 monstrosity too petrified to
move terrified of being caught and
turned into another of the fleshy
nightmares Eliza stayed hidden this was
it she thought to herself any moment now
one of those things would find her
either breaking through the
street-facing window of the coffee shop
or slithering in through the rear fire
door sure enough the flesh formerly
known as Mike the Barista turned where
had once there been a head was now a
featureless blob that had fused with the
shoulder but Eliza could tell its
eyeless stare was being directed at her
and she had nowhere to run Mike's arm
which was now a slimy blood red tentacle
began slamming against the glass cracks
forming a across the surface Eliza's
eyes darted around the room trying to
look for some kind of way out her
options were limited and even then they
didn't amount to more than hiding in a
storage cupboard and prolonging the
inevitable she needed a miracle as if to
answer her prayers a blinding white
light erupted from somewhere out of view
beyond the window Turning Away Eliza had
to Shield her eyes from the Searing glow
blinking away spots in her vision as she
looked to see what had happened the
scp-610 creature Mike had vanished a
dark outline scorched against the glass
as if it had been obliterated by an
intense focused blast that light
whatever it was had vaporized it the
sound of commotion came bustling through
the door a distorted mechanical sounding
voices called out hello is anyone there
hello is anyone in here one garbled we
mean you no harm another said but you
need to to leave this place as soon as
you can cautiously Eliza stood up from
under the table standing at the entrance
to the coffee shop where a trio of
figures each one of them had Machinery
all manner of metallic components
protruding from their bodies replacing
arms legs parts of their faces Eliza
stared at them unsure whether these
cyborgs were as harmless as they claimed
one even had a cannon in place of one of
their hands which was still smoking from
the blast that had killed the scp-610
instances outside did the flush make
contact with you one of the figures
asked no Eliza replied that's how they
spread right it's like an infection I
watched it happen indeed the cyborg with
the Canon arm replied The Flash being
loose is only the beginning if you are
uninfected then we'd ask you to come
with us we'll explain on the way hang on
who are you Eliza asked concern on her
face and where are you taking me we are
the Church of the broken God one of them
answered and we're getting you out of
New York the idea of a person making
their way out of the city that never
sleeps on foot would be laughable to
anyone that lived there even before it
had become overrun with monsters but the
subway wasn't exactly running on time
and the roads were gridlocked with cars
that had either been destroyed or
abandoned by their owners so walking out
of New York was the only option the
Church of the broken God cyborgs
explained to Eliza as much as they knew
about what had happened they described
an organization a secret cabal with
power spanning the entire world called
the SCP Foundation apparently this
Foundation had been responsible for
Gathering and safeguarding the world
from dangerous and unexplained phenomena
you mean like those flesh things she
asked exactly they called those
scp-610 but recently something had
changed the foundation had turned its
seemingly inexhaustible resources to the
goal of Exterminating Humanity it was by
their hands that instances of scp-610
had been Unleashed in major cities not
just New York but Delhi Tokyo London and
countless others those were far from the
only anomalies the foundation had
deployed either as they walked the
cyborgs described how someone called Mr
Deeds had been the fascinating heads of
state the world over they also spoke of
a horrifying reptile that was now
running wild and slaughtering everything
in its path we at the church had to act
whatever the foundation's reasons for
unleashing this hell we couldn't sit by
and allow them to destroy everything so
we've aligned ourselves with the global
occult coalition to assist them in
fighting against the flesh that hates in
exchange we have vowed to help transport
survivors to safety but where can we
possibly go that's safe Eliza
interjected If the foundation had the
reach you say they do if they have all
these horrible creatures at their
disposal what chance do we have at
surviving well there is always our path
one of the broken God's followers
replied the path of standardization
becoming one with machine our mechanized
pods are safe from the flesh's
corruption if you would consider joining
us Eliza took a quick glance at the
metallic components of her cyborg
companions they look like they heard as
much as becoming a scp-610 monster would
have she politely declined although it
led to the rest of their Journey
continuing in an awkward silence
eventually the broken God cyborgs
brought Eliza to an extraction point
where they left her in the care of the
global occodes Coalition boarding a
convoy her and a number of others were
ferried out of New York state by the GOC
for the first time since this had all
started Eliza started to think that
maybe she was heading to somewhere safe
that sliver of hope all Came Crashing
Down the moment the Convoy was attacked
armed assailants opened fire on the
trucks they were quickly identified by
Coalition soldiers as members of the SC
foundation's mobile task forces Special
Operations troops sent out to pick off
survivors in the midst of the fire fight
gunfire erupting all around her Eliza
never felt so terrified one of the GOC
officers turned to her as they crouched
behind cover listen I shouldn't be
telling you this but there's rumors of a
Survivor settlement not far from here He
barked I'll draw their fire you run get
as far away from here fast as you can
and don't look back doing as she was
told Eliza sprinted away from the
wreckage of the Convoy until her legs
refused to run any further she trudged
alone through an empty Town abandoned it
felt like a place out of a nightmare the
world was decimated virtually
post-apocalyptic the further she willed
herself to walk the more she could feel
herself giving up that she would never
even find the settlement if it even
existed at all hope had abandoned her
and at her lowest point Eliza dug her
heels in and dropped to the ground both
exhausted and convinced she'd been
hiking towards nothing the feeling of
being moved caused Eliza to stir waking
her up from a dream that had been almost
as Bleak as her new reality someone was
carrying her on what felt like a
stretcher she quickly realized before
she had a chance to ask who they were
the pair of shadowy human shapes brought
her through the woods to what looked
like a campsite don't be alarmed one of
them said in a voice that sounded so
optimistic it felt almost alien as if
this person was from another planet
where things were far less horrible
looking around Eliza noticed the glow of
a campfire Illuminating the nearby trees
a handful of people were huddled
together in makeshift tents resting and
wearing contented almost Happy
Expressions then Eliza's eyes were drawn
towards something else some slimy Mass
gliding around the camp at first she
thought it was another instance of
scp-610 until she saw an amorphous
gelatinous orange blob glowing in the
Fire Light to the foundation it had been
known as SCP 999 but to its Newfound
family of human survivors this creature
was their savior a Bastion of Hope and
happiness in a devastated hellscape the
Tickle Monster welcomed into the
Survivor Community with open arms Eliza
was soon exposed to
scp-999's anomalous effects the creature
seemed to warm to her instantly greeting
her with the enthusiastic friendliness
of a small dog even after as little as a
single interaction with it she felt her
lack of Hope and depressed feelings
towards the bleakness of the world had
almost entirely faded she felt happiness
pure genuine happiness for the first
time in recent memory thanks to the
Tickle Monster Eliza's entire Outlook
had completely changed the same was true
for the other survivors that had formed
a settlement around the happy orange
creature they had all come seeking an
escape not just a physical place that
was out of Harm's Way but somewhere they
could reject the harsh reality of what
the SCP Foundation had done to the world
and scp-999 had provided that for them
all curing the displaced refugees of
their woes keeping them in perpetually
High Spirits most of them had reached
such a point of contentment that they'd
forgotten their old lives before the
collapse before the anomalies and the
foundation although the Tickle Monster
demanded nothing of its Newfound family
apart from the occasional playful tickle
wrestle Eliza and a group of the other
survivors would venture back to the
nearby abandoned town just beyond the
woods once there they would scavenge for
as much food as they could find keeping
a close eye out for any candy with which
to feed scp-999 even though they knew
999 was more than happy to provide
positivity to the survivors each one of
them felt it was the least they could do
for their favorite orange slime ball
there was such a continuous state of
love and happiness in their camp that
the survivors were hardly phased when a
foundation Soldier inadvertently
stumbled upon their settlement before he
could raise his weapon and fire
scp-999 slid between its friends and the
soldier blocking the path of his bullets
without any shred of malice or hostility
the delightful blob leaped towards the
attacking MTF operative and embraced him
instantly the foundation foot soldiers
demeanor changed before he had been
glassy-eyed motionless like something
deep inside him had broken but after
their hug parted the man was euphoric
grinning in a state of elation for long
afterwards for a Time Eliza sat with the
soldier Sergeant Kalos and listened to
him explaining how he wanted to renounce
the foundation to stay with this
community of survivors now he knew as CP
999 was here do you remember anything
from before she asked curiously before
Kalos echoed you mean before the
foundation did all this Eliza nodded
remembering the outside world was hazy
now like trying to recall the vague
details of a dream not much the former
MTF Trooper answered they wanted us to
to kill everyone because of it what like
the Stephen King book no
Kalos chuckled they told us it had
latched itself on to everyone all human
subconsciousness it had plans something
really really awful So the foundation's
plan was to wipe everyone out wouldn't
that include everyone who works for the
foundation no they um
altered us made it so we couldn't feel
pain anymore he paused and began
giggling uncontrollably as if he had
just understood the punch line to a joke
in fact Kalos said between fits of
laughter that's probably how 999 was
able to fix me next to him Eliza
couldn't help but laugh too the humor
was infectious because you couldn't feel
pain she giggled yeah
callous exploded delighted tears rolling
down his face I lost the capacity for it
I was hollowed out and that would have
made it easy for scp-999 to fill that
space with this
rolled over onto the floor still
chortling unstoppably and this didn't
stop for hours the tickle Monster's
powers of positivity had increased
exponentially since it had found itself
free from the foundation facility it had
used to live at much like callow had
explained to Eliza it had allowed The
Lovable blob to correct the alteration
the foundation had made to the former
MTF Sergeant allowing him to feel
Euphoria in the place of his total
absence of all pain and now thanks to
the influence of scp-999 the threat
posed by both the SCP Foundation and
whatever this it entity was seems so far
away so irrelevant and did little to
dampen the High Spirits of the survivors
in the camp but in their Collective
sense of bliss Eliza scp-999 and the
other survivors became a little
oblivious to the outside world and its
Horrors little did they know there was
still danger lurking much closer than
they realized one that had spread from
miles away and and would very soon be at
the settlement it was Eliza and callow
that first discovered what was lurking
nearby they had both been searching for
food in the ruins of the Old Town beyond
the woods which felt more and more like
a completely different world the longer
they spent in the camp with scp-999 as
Eliza rummaged through the storeroom of
an abandoned Supermarket she heard a
scream of Agony coming from nearby
callow for the first time in months
Panic fear and adrenaline rocked her
system it almost made her feel sick she
had been so overloaded with positive
endorphins that it had practically
numbed her to all other feelings but
Instinct kicked in fight or flight
hitting her with the force of an ice
cold bucket of water and she ran out
into the store to look for callow what
she saw gave her a terrified knot in her
stomach the kind she hadn't felt since
the day the nightmare had started the
flesh that hates an instance of scp-610
was standing in the aisles of the empty
Supermarket the site of the grotesque
mutated form shuffling towards her made
Eliza freeze on the spot it took a
further moment to realize that callow
had long since stopped screaming Eliza's
thoughts had picked up speed for the
first time in months she was processing
information without it being dulled by
the Euphoria brought on by scp-999 it
made her realize that this scp-610 had
either killed callow and he'd soon be
turning into one of those flesh
creatures for this was callow and he'd
already changed Thinking Fast Eliza
sprinted through the supermarket hearing
the snarls of the flesh coming after her
she passed a shopping cart and in an
instance grabbed its handlebar turning
the metal cage around and racing full
force towards the scp-610 instance
chasing her the card collided with the
blood red mass of the flesh the sheer
force knocking the creature onto its
back and giving Eliza a window of
opportunity to race out of the
supermarket watched by a gaggle of
mutated creatures those of them that
still had eyes followed her movements as
she ran back towards the woods toward
the camp and slowly the flesh that hates
began to fall out from the moment that
she returned to the settlement scp-999
could immediately sense that Eliza was
in a state of panic instinctively the
creature glided up to her only seeking
to comfort her and make her forget about
whatever had troubled her no stop she
protested as much as she wanted to not
worry about the impending Danger
scp-999 recquelled from her a wounded
expression on its gooey orange face I'm
sorry it's just we're all in serious
trouble Eliza urged the other survivors
gathered around lazily each of them
seeming upbeat despite her grave news
the flesh scp-610 they're here they
found us she explained they killed
callow and it won't take them long to
find us they won't come here one of the
survivors replied not argumentatively
but in a more uplifting and reassuring
tone none of the other anomalies offend
Us in months another interjected smiling
not even the foundation can get us here
we're protected the Tickle Monster keeps
us all safe but what if it can't protect
us from the flesh Eliza desperately
tried to warn her fellow survivors but
they were in too much of a Carefree
state to fear the approach of the flesh
that hates a number of them tried to
convince her to relax spend some time
with the Tickle Monster so she wouldn't
feel as bad as appealing as that sounded
Eliza didn't want to let her guard down
she felt she owed scp-999 for keeping
her and the others alive for helping
them forget the horrific world the
foundation had Unleashed and even if she
was the only one she'd protect it night
had fallen the sound of every snapping
twig felt like he could be one of the
scp-610s approaching the rest of the
camp was fast asleep save for Eliza
wielding a flaming branch in one hand to
ward off the flesh sure enough through
the Shadows of the woods and the low
light of her torch she saw shapes began
to shuffle towards her the Slick bloody
creatures looked even worse in the dark
shambling over to Eliza a backing away
cautiously as she brandished her flame
but the flesh that hates was closing in
more and more of them slithering out
from between the trees causing her to
step back in the direction of the camp
suddenly an excitable orange mask swept
past Eliza under the Torchlight she saw
scp-999 approaching the flushing
mutations no she cried out horrified at
what they would do to her Camp's
protector to her surprise the flesh
stopped in their tracks as the Tickle
Monster wriggled up to them they seemed
to get closer examining the orange goop
as it grinned at them then as if they
had lost their innate hostility to
anything that they hadn't yet infected
the scp-610 creatures Turned and Left
perhaps it was something within the
slimy substance the Tickle Monster was
made of that repelled the flesh that
hates or maybe it was because it was
such a sheer force of overwhelming good
and its increased power that allowed
scp-9999 to pacify the monstrosities
either way Eliza breathed eye of relief
the grinning orange blob turned to her
and smiled leaping up into her arms and
allowing her to carry it back to Camp as
scp-999 turned her relief into happiness
once again it seemed that no matter how
Bleak the world might be even in a
timeline as horrifying as that of
scp-5000 wherever the Tickle Monster
goes there will always be the promise of
positivity and with it a sliver of Hope
from the friendliest anomaly of all scps
will come and go we know that but the
most important thing in life will always
be the anomalies at this containment
site right here right now that's family
thank you Dr Toretto for that inspiring
speech family can mean many things to
many people and when it comes to the
bizarre world of scps family can be
found in some very unexpected places
take the two brothers Cain and Abel
scp-073 and
scp-076-2 respectively as an example
their shared history goes back centuries
and from when little we've been able to
learn directly from the source the two
seem to have the mother of all sibling
rivalries Abel can become visibly
enraged at the very mention of Kane's
name whereas Kane has a more subdued
response calmly but firmly urging
inquisitive researchers not to discuss
the matter any further whatever bad
blood came between them is not fully
known but it likely has something to do
with the nature of their anomalous
abilities Kane has the power to drain
the lives of plant life with merely a
touch while Abel has the power of
Resurrection returning from the grave
every time he was dealt a lethal blow
the two were natural opposites and yet
they were also undeniably family and
their case is not wholly unique within
the SCP Foundation as there is also
another pair of completely antithetical
beings in containment who surprisingly
share a family tree and much like the
diamond dynamic between scp-073 and
scp-076-2 there was one side of the pair
that could express nothing but distress
at the mere mention of the other and it
was by far not the one that most would
expect enter
scp-682 one of the most deadly ketter
class scps that the foundation had ever
known a reptilian monstrosity
responsible for multiple containment
breaches capable of withstanding the
total punishment of weapons both
conventional and anomalous and hell-bent
on following through on the personal
violent destruction of every living
being in existence it is an anomalous
creature so overwhelmingly powerful and
indestructible that one could easily
assume that it was incapable of fear and
in most cases that would be an astute
observation but not when it comes to the
matter of scp-999 the Tickle Monster in
stark contrast to scp-682's viciousness
scp-9 199 is a bundle of pure
unadulterated Bliss resembling a smiley
face glob of sunshine and honey
scp-9999's main anomalous property is
its ability to bring lasting joy to all
beings that interact with it for long
contact with the little guy has even
been proven to cure depression and ease
trauma what's more
scp-999 seems to actively seek out
others to share these benefits with and
often does so through play or other
forms of socialization
scp-999 is benevolent in just about
every way that a being could be and that
makes it very different from most of the
Sapient anomalies in containment it is
especially different from scp-682 even
though they have a common origin while
the family resemblance is far from
striking these two scps are half
siblings not as closely related as Cain
and Abel but that is still a lot closer
than most researchers would expect both
of them were allegedly born from Human
mothers who had undergone a horrific
ritual at the hands of an obscure cult
known as the children of the Scarlet
King as the ominous name of the cult
implies the members of the children of
the Scarlet King worshiped a nightmarish
deity known as The Scarlet King this
interdimensional super being has become
known to the SCP Foundation as one of
the most threatening anomalous forces in
existence and some have even suggested
that the Scarlet King is the ultimate
threat that the foundation must overcome
if they wish to achieve their goals to
put it a different way the Scarlet King
is like the last boss of a traditional
RPG video game a primal source of all
evil and suffering in the world which
must be defeated at any cost his powers
are so great that our world is merely
one of many that he aims to conquer and
reduce to rubble and ruin and all of us
mortals can take a bit of solace in the
fact that the Scarlet King split
interests mean that he is unlike to
invade our world directly anytime soon
is not without his schemes and
contingencies though of which the vile
machinations of the children of the
Scarlet King were surely one the two
ordinary human woman who would go on to
give birth to both scp-682 and scp-999
were part of a group of seven
individuals total all of whom had been
imprisoned by the children of the
Scarlet King and were found in the late
stages of pregnancy at the Colts
compound upon being discovered by the
SCP Foundation these women were placed
in containment and designated
scp-231 over the duration of their
containment the instances of scp-231
have given birth to various anomalies
most of these anomalies have been
catastrophically dangerous Qatar class
anomalies and have each been the cause
of hundreds of casualties those which
could be destroyed through violence were
neutralized before ever receiving a
designation with the obvious exception
being scp-682
despite the foundation's best efforts
even more exceptional is scp-999 which
while just as anomalous and nigh
indestructible as the others did not
share its siblings capacity for cruelty
and Slaughter of all the humans that
were unlucky enough to become part of
scp-231 only the mother of scp-999 was
able to survive and make a full recovery
from the trauma that she suffered at the
hands of the cult this unexpectedly
happy outcome was apparently thanks to
scp-9999's ability to heal those around
it including its human mother
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile and
scp-999 the Tickle Monster are the two
most notable members of The scp-231
Brood and while the Scarlet King had
more than likely hoped that his actual
biological children would join forces to
drown our world in misery and pain this
will most likely never come to pass that
is because
scp-682 and
scp-9999 are like oil and water and the
one that has been successful in Rising
above the other has unmistakably been as
CP 999 this surprising truth became
known to the foundation after a rather
eventful cross-test between the two most
contrary spawn of the Scarlet king and
the findings from that experiment Point
towards a possible long-term solution in
dealing with the interdimensional Elder
evil as well as his children adopted or
otherwise the cross test was the product
of resilient optimism from the research
team who Against All Odds were willing
to bet that scp-999 could survive an
encounter with one of the most infamous
Qatar class scps the foundation had on
record nobody could be 100 sure that 999
would come out of the test unscathed and
there was not an insubstantial amount of
fear as everyone's favorite glob of
goodness was wheeled into a shared
containment for the experiment to be
carried out however the mere presence of
scp-999 sue the great deal of the
worried Souls which only instilled more
confidence in the head researchers that
this would lead to a success once
scp-999 was alone in the cell with
scp-682 the main event could begin
scp-682 had been subjected to a wide
variety of cross-tests during its time
in containment and having never met or
been aware of scp-999 prior to the test
was cautiously staring the creature down
preparing for the absolute worst with a
beaming smile on its face
scp-999 slid forward towards the reptile
causing the ketterclass SCP to
instinctively step backward in response
there was something deeply unsettling
about this gooey little glob to scp-682
but it couldn't fathom what from
appearance the overseers of the Cross
test were stunned the site of 682
retreating from an entity was rare to
say the least and the adorable
unimposing shape of scp-999 made the
scene playing out inside the contain
area especially surreal but no matter
how unlikely it's seen
scp-999 had begun The Sibling play date
with an insurmountable psychological
advantage as the Tickle Monster move
ever closer
scp-682 found itself backed into a
corner with no further options the
reptile brought one of its massive claws
down on top of the smiling blob the
entire mass of scp-999 was splattered
into jelly upon impact for a moment it
seemed as though that was it the
researchers held their breath in shock
hoping that scp-999 would pull through
and then their wish came true the
amorphous form of scp-999 began to
reshape itself into the recognizable
form that we all know and love it
proceeded to crawl up scp-682's body
towards the nape of its snack once there
the Tickle Monster began doing what it
does best cuddles and lots of them 682
was certainly caught off guard by this
unusual occurrence and more than that it
falling fast under scp-999 spell of
benevolence the lizard began to stomp
its claws overcome with sun bouts of
uproarious laughter it began to vocalize
in a way that seemed
uncharacteristically enthusiastic for
the ketterclass anomaly happy happy
I feel so happy repeated 682 as it
rolled around and thrashed in the
cross-testing containment chamber the
merciless tickling from scp-999 looked
like it would be torturous for the big
reptile to endure if it wasn't so much
fun on the sidelines the foundation
Personnel cheered on their wonderful
little friend 999 as it continued to
tickle scp-682 without stopping some of
the staff present were even sporting
custom t-shirts that read
scp-9999 literally cured my depression
the Tickle Monster did have a large fan
base within its containment facility
after all and returning some of the Good
Vibes that the anomaly had provided
seemed like the right thing to do at a
time like this
scp-682's fits a laughter continued for
a long while and the more it went on the
more it seemed that scp-682 was becoming
tired 999 seemed to sense its siblings
energy level decreasing ceased the
Relentless tickling and instead began to
nuzzle 682 and purr into the lizard's
ears slowly the quiet and pleasant
sounds of scp-99 lulled 682 into a
peaceful Slumber the hard to destroy
reptile curled up on the floor of the
containment cell almost like a sleeping
cat and began to gently snore away once
it's older and more cantankerous sibling
had fallen completely asleep
scp-999 slithered off
scp-682's back and settled down nearby
to rest its own eyes the research team
couldn't help but smile and observe for
several minutes before eventually
removing 999 from the cross-test
containment cell predictably this caused
scp-682 to revert back to its usual
violent behavior and a containment
region sued shortly after however the
casualties were kept to a minimum as
scp-999 bravely helped escort several
dozen Foundation Personnel to safety by
itself what would we do without you 999
we know what scp-682 would do without
scp-999 of course the hard to destroy
reptile would be far less threatened
while scp-999 had expressed continued
interest in another play date with 682
the exact opposite sentiment has been
reported from its reptilian sibling and
it is simply not a lack of affection
there is an underlying fear that
motivates
scp-682's desire to never interact with
scp-999 again while some researchers
speculated that scp-682 felt an
incredible sense of Shame when it was
observed being tickled this is more of
an armchair assumption that projects
typical human psychology onto an
anomalous being we cannot forget that
scp-682 was born of the Scarlet King and
while scp-999 possesses the inverse of
its father's traits
scp-682 might have directly inherited
the template for its emotional
intelligence from that very same being
While most well-adjusted humans try to
avoid supposedly negative stimuli such
as embarrassment anger sadness and fear
and seek out positive stimuli I.E
happiness pleasure security and Trust
alien beings with Twisted Minds like the
Scarlet King might have these priorities
reversed to scp-682 all other living
things are disgusting and it wishes to
destroy them but when this tendency is
examined within the context of both
scp-999 and what we know about the
Scarlet King it becomes clear that
scp-682 isn't an excessively prideful
being moreover
scp-682 doesn't believe that it is doing
the world or itself a service by
eliminating the aforementioned
disgusting beings we have theorized that
scp-682 and scp-99 9 are equal and
opposite but if that proves to be true
on the level of internal psyche
scp-682 might compulsively attack other
beings for the same reason that scp-999
Comforts them it is a continuous
expression of empathy or more accurately
whatever one might call The Impossible
inverse of empathy
scp-682 and the Scarlet King are not
merely indifferent to the suffering of
others both of them need to be in the
presence of those suffering beings in
order to feel any sense of meaning in
their existence after all love is the
strongest emotion but hate is the second
strongest imagine now if you can y-682
fears 999 a being that represents every
unwanted sensation and emotion that it
lives its Immortal Life hoping to avoid
in the eyes of scp-682
scp-999 is precisely as horrifying as
the reptile is to ourselves the scaled
class starship in Nobis was still
suspended against a backdrop of stars
and the colorful glow of distant nebulas
Frozen in the inky void of deep space
calm at least from the outside but
inside the main hall of the ship was far
from the silent Stillness of the Stars
pandemonium hit as the sounds of a
claxon reverberated through metal
corridors each whale punctuated by the
flash of blood red warning lights blue
looked up at the blinking strobing color
and instantly knew what it meant
emergency meeting he muttered to himself
behind the visor of his spacesuit blue
turned heel and ran his boots clanging
against the metal floor of the corridor
he ran as fast as he could in his
spacesuit arriving panting to the
cafeteria his breathless wheezes fogged
up his visor but beyond he could still
see the other six fellow members of the
ship's crew or to thought all six of
them were there it was only as he walked
closer that he spotted someone was
missing white red green orange yellow
and now blue were all present but where
was pink you took your time blue white
declared I was over at the lower engine
he pan it back it's further away sorry
I'm late ran as fast as I could what's
the situation here orange asked well I I
think we should wait for pink to get her
before we get into red started to say
only to be interrupted that's why I
called the meeting green announced pink
has gone missing but that's impossible
red immediately responded drawing a
glare from White I saw pink only a few
moments ago we were both over an
electrical to Blue along with some of
the others that seemed a little bit odd
if red and pink had been close to each
other then Howard Green known to call
the emergency meeting the room erupted
into a brief debate with white implying
in a rather spiteful way that red knew
more than he was letting on interjecting
blue suggested that they all split up
and search for pink which was quickly
shot down white reminded the rest of the
crewmates that their ship was in need of
constant maintenance if they didn't
perform the necessary tasks to keep it
running then the anobis would never
reach its destination report back here
when you're finished white barked as
they all split off blue couldn't help
but wonder what had gotten white more
agitated than normal however little did
any of the crew aboard the anovis
realize but they had picked up a
stowaway the creature had been slipping
through the ventilation system curiously
watching the assembled group in the
cafeteria before they broke away and
headed off into the various different
areas of the ship spotting one of the
crewmates a man wearing a bright orange
spacesuit the thing in the vents felt
oddly drawn to him and slithered off
down the vents in the direction orange
had been heading now while you might be
forgiven for at first expecting this
extra passenger to be some kind of Alien
Parasite that uses human bodies as
before bursting out of their chest only
to then proceed to kill everything in
sight then you'd be sorely mistaken
Stand Down Sigourney there are no
Xenomorphs aboard this ship no this
slippery little stowaway was none other
than the lovable blob of orange slime
known as scp-999 otherwise referred to
as the Tickle Monster known for being an
adorable amorphous anomaly resembling a
pile of gelatinous orange matter
scp-999 has long been considered one of
the most harmless and affectionate scp's
ever cataloged it has a habit of honing
in on the nearest person and leaping
right at them not as a means to attack
them or attach any scary eight-legged
egg-laying head-hugging creature to any
faces instead as CP 999 offers a loving
Embrace and wholesome nuzzling to a
person's face all the while emitting
soothing gurgling and cooing noises as
well as pleasant scents that change
depending on what the person it's
hugging finds most appealing or calm
while not in any way harmful and only
ever acting out of the most well-man
intentions
scp-999 had been the one responsible for
Pink's disappearance the Tickle Monster
had been discovered by Pink while he was
traveling through a corridor past the
med Bay taking the longer route back to
electrical there 999 had playfully
pounced on the crewmate to offer a hug
this had caused pink to experience the
full effect of
scp-9999's anomalous properties slipping
into an overwhelmingly elated state so
while not currently injured he was
calmly relaxing in a hidden corner of
the med Bay with the rest of the crew
completely unaware of what was going on
scp-9999 had spotted orange and had been
able to recognize the same color as its
own jello-like body drawn to the
crewmate the Tickle Monster snuck
towards orange while his back was turned
busy cleaning out the filters in the O2
chamber before he could turn around and
spot the creature scp-999 left to Orange
and lowered into to the med Bay with
pink not long after blue had finished up
his latest task fixing up the wiring and
storage brushing off his hands he began
casually walking back in the direction
of the cafeteria only to see the Crimson
of red spacesuit zip past he was rushing
down the corridor almost like he had
just been caught well red handed
something didn't seem right blue thought
to himself red had seemed pretty
indignant earlier when pink had vanished
although he couldn't say with any
certainty if it was because red really
did know what was going on or if they
were just nervous returning to the
cafeteria however the crew quickly
realized that orange was now gone too
I'm calling it now white declared this
was you red you're up to something I I'm
not red pleated it was hard to see how
sincere's expression was through the
tinted space helmet visor well if anyone
else knows anything or saw anything then
come forward white said to the group the
rest of the crew were awkwardly
shuffling on their feet each one clearly
uncertain but nobody wanting to come
forward and be the first to speak
actually I um blue found themselves
saying I saw red dashing around in the
corridor he seemed like he was in a
hurry or maybe he was up to something
maybe look it doesn't prove anything you
don't know that yellow chimed in who
knows he may have been eyeing you up as
his next victim victim red exclaimed
look I don't know what you're implying
here I haven't killed anyone nobody said
pink and orange were dead white replied
unless you know more than you're letting
on I swear I don't know what's happening
I'm just in the dark as you all are red
insisted in that case prove it green
interjected bluntly prove you didn't
kill orange and pink how red yelled how
can I prove that you could prove they're
both still alive said yellow completely
unaware that pink and orange were
actually still alive he can't prove it
white announced solemnly because I bet
they're not even on the ship anymore the
missing crewmates were in actuality
still aboard the ship in fact they were
having the time of their lives inside
the med Bay with scp-999 but that hadn't
stopped the rest of the crew turning on
red come on red blue side I mean you've
got to admit you're acting a little well
not suspicious but definitely evasive oh
sure what just because I'm wearing red
you all think I'm some kind of murderous
traitor red shouted his desperate
pleading tears obscured by his helmet's
visor this is McCarthyism look why don't
you just give us a straight answer blue
offered trying to remain reasonable and
not join the rapidly growing Witch Hunt
because I'm scared red insisted scare
that we'll find out white yelled leaping
at red and pinning him down quick the
rest of you grab his arms and legs a
struggle in
with red desperately kicking and
flailing about while green and yellow
gripped an arm and leg blue was
reluctant he wanted to urge everyone to
calm down and not do anything irrational
but it was already too late if he
opposed the blame might shift to him
under White's Direction the crew lifted
red up and carried him to the anovis's
outer airlock they threw red past the
inside door which slammed shut behind
him as he turned and started slamming
his hand against the surface begging for
them to let him out his pleas fell on
deaf ears as white threw a nearby switch
the outer door of the airlock opened the
vacuum of space pulled red out of the
ship practically firing him out of a
hull like a cannon leaving him to drift
away alone and with limited oxygen in
his spacesuit right now that imposter's
been dealt with everyone get back to
work white announced we need to keep
this ship in a fit state to move blue
was speechless he thought they were just
going to hold red prisoner in a secure
part of the ship until he calmed down
instead he'd aided his crew States in
murdering one of their own even the very
thought of it made blue feel sick and he
would have been if he wasn't wearing a
space helmet it all happened so fast
he'd barely had enough time to consider
all the facts after all white had seemed
adamant from the very start that red was
somehow responsible for orange and pink
disappearing but he had no concrete
evidence to base that assumption on then
again where were those missing crewmates
there had been no sign of them no bodies
or discarded suits maybe they weren't on
the ship at all anymore what if white
was right and red had killed them or
Worse what if White had been the one
responsible and blue would just helped
him kill an innocent Spaceman to cover
up his cruel misdeeds of course the
surviving crew were so wrapped up in the
horrifying moral and ethical
implications of the situation that none
of them had thought to check the med Bay
meanwhile scp-999 had found two more new
friends green and yellow the parrot
seemed rather glum since they they just
helped kill red and so the orange blob
of Good Vibes had sought them out now
the two of them plus orange and pink who
were still fine were all enjoying the
company of the Tickle Monster in the med
Bay at the same time though blue was
returning from his tasks of uploading
data over an admin to find only white
left waiting for him in the cafeteria
neither one of them said anything they'd
both already made up their minds in each
one's head the other was the real guilty
party the culprit responsible for the
disappearances and apparent deaths of
the other crewmates both blue and white
were convinced that the other was truly
the Imposter Among Us
oh God enraged they charged at each
other rather than act rationally Maybe
by sticking together and searching the
rest of the ship the two Spacemen
engaged each other in a scuffle your
sauce blue roared punching white in the
stomach causing him to stagger backwards
I'm not the one who sucks white
rushing back towards blue and shoulder
barging him into the cafeteria floor
they continued their scrap trading blows
until blue was able to throw a punch
that cracked the glass visor of White's
helmet there was a hiss as the air
escaped and white was desperately
fumbling with his helmet trying to plug
the crack blue was able to grab him by
his oxygen tank and drag him towards the
airlock blasting his adversary out into
the unforgiving cold emptiness of space
blue staggered through the ship it was
certain that he received a broken rib
during the fight and hobbled along the
corridors towards Med Bay when the
entrance opened he stared in disbelief
at what he saw sat inside were the
entire crew minus the pair who'd been
ejected from the airlock of course pink
orange green and yellow were playing
with a friendly blob of orange slime
that seemed to have the energy and
enthusiasm of a peck dog the crewmates
were laughing hugging the Tickle Monster
and engaging in tickle fights clearly in
a state of heightened Elation in a
sudden instant of realization the horror
caught up with blue he had just murdered
white and red for enough
both of them were innocent in fact
nobody on the ship was actually missing
just before this horrifying Epiphany
caused blue to suffer an emotional
breakdown
scp-999 glided across the floor towards
him smiling as he knelt to Pat the
orange blob on the head blue suddenly
felt better about the two deaths he'd
been responsible for actually he felt
great compelled to start giggling
uncontrollably as he joined his fellow
surviving crewmates in playing with the
stowaway as CP 999 although thanks to
that delightful distraction not one of
the remaining astronauts realized that
their ship was still adrift in space
heading right towards a sun now go check
out scp-999 the Tickle Monster and
scp-5167 when the imposterous sus for
more blobs and imposters